hey what's going on it's Bill Burr and
it's time for the Thursday afternoon
just before Friday Monday Morning
podcast and ah just checking in on you
just checking to see how your week's
doing usually it's just me checking in
on you but occasionally
I'll have a guest someone I just can't
resist you know I used to live out in
Massachusetts I used to be a real person
then I came out to Hollywood and I
became a big phony and they got to know
all kinds of celebrities and one of my
favorite celebrities
better
I've gotten to work with is the one and
only Nick Kroll who has a stand-up
special called Little Big Man Little Big
Boy little big boy and his animated
series wildly successful on Netflix
comes out at the end of this month big
mouth and he is here to promote both of
those because this man has more irons in
the fire than a [ __ ] cowboy in the
1800s how are you sir I'm good I'm I'm
proud to be thought of as one of your
favorite Hollywood phony friends so yeah
thrilled to be here
you used to be one of my Hollywood
friends then you got a pool and that's
when you upgraded
Hollywood you gotta have a pool
never in it and you've got to be on the
phone screaming at somebody truly I am
never in my pool I feel as though I've
become allergic to my pool so as a true
now I'm Philly now one of your Hollywood
phony neurotic Jewish uh friends you
cannot put himself he wants the world to
feel bad for him because he doesn't have
time for his big Hollywood pool because
he's so busy promoting all of his
successful projects they're relatable
trying to find a way to be relatable
bill
can you agree yeah trying to get Joe's
six-pack here so tell me uh where did
you shoot your special the Warner
Theater in DC
uh you know it I'm sure yeah I shot a
special how do you like those those
Crowds Are like like on the left and the
right are really conservative because I
feel like everybody there is uh in the
business in the yes another industry
Town
um but this one they really [ __ ] you you
know what I mean
um I like DC I saved DC for that part I
saved DC for the tour because I do find
them to be a smart audience as opposed
to LA or New York and Boston's the same
way and I'm playing Fenway in a week I'd
like to promote that as well I'm doing
three nights I don't know how many you
did but oh you couldn't even just say
two you got to say three yeah I'm doing
three so um but I I like DC they're
smart like but they're not like over it
like New York and La you know what I
mean they're still excited that you're
coming through uh that theater is
beautiful it's got you know it's kind of
grand and in how it looks and so I had
been waiting for the whole tour which
got kind of broken up in the middle of
the pandemic to to go do it it was great
it was is really fun it was if you want
yeah it's nerve-wracking yeah you have
it done and then you just walk around
anybody you see like was that good was
that good was it good homeless guy on
the way back to the hotel did you see it
did you hear it
the homeless guy's like you got it it's
in there it's in there somewhere you got
it on the first one yeah now you just
have fun yeah you just have fun
everybody said every one of them it was
great it was great perfect we got it now
just go out there and have fun in other
words you were tight as a drum loosen
the [ __ ] up before we all lose six
figures on this piece of [ __ ]
um speaking of just saying you know
you're saying New York New York and La
is over it I think this whole country is
over it anytime I watch uh
uh concert footage of one of my favorite
bands when they're in like South America
I just saw uh some clip of guns and
roses and they were playing Welcome to
the Jungle and they're just playing the
beginning
doing 80 000 people in unison were
jumping up and down
screaming and then screaming all of the
lyrics
and I remember I was just looking at
that going like these bands when they
once they tour South America they must
come back to America
this country and just be like this
[ __ ] this is this feels like a church
meeting it's true I think I mean it's I
mean it's the cameras it's it's so much
of it as the cameras I think they just
immediately like guns and roses and then
everyone just is like you know what I
mean they're just filming they've lost
all sense of it uh and I and I've seen a
couple especially bands like that you go
to South America they love heavy metal
like they just are I mean guns row is
not being heavy metal but like they
still think like that rot I mean that's
like the center of their you know like
Sepultura can still play like 80 000
seaters right yeah but dude in the 80s
when I I would go to concerts you know
we went nuts we didn't go like that
no maybe maybe like the encore
but AC DC would have to be shooting off
cannons and even then we're just like
yeah
let's do some drugs far out you know we
weren't like
the entire audience going yeah do you
remember your first concert what was
your first concert
uh Judas Priest with Doc and open up on
the uh fuel for Life tour there you go
Mr Central I I saw the real original
Judas Priest the guy who created the
thing to plant uh
to plant uh uh seeds in the ground I
went and saw him speak uh how was that
yeah it was great it was really
informative I learned a lot about
biblical cultivation
Nick I miss hanging out with you man I
haven't seen you all right we're jumping
back in now okay we're back in all right
wait wait wait wait wait we just we just
cut out because I always like cut out
[ __ ] if it's too much personal
information and I've gotten that from
there was something on Netflix
called uh don't [ __ ] with cats did you
see that yes yeah and all they had was
they caught this serial killer because
he was torturing these cats to death
they didn't know he was a serial killer
and all they had was like just a little
like bed
and like some beige wall and from the
the bed sheets and all of that stuff
they were able to figure out what city
the building and they ended up finding
the guy
and uh not before you know he killed
some people but yeah
[Music]
only he killed cats bill
I'm not into that man
you're not into you're not in a kill I
feel like you're a dog guy do you have
any sense of humor when people kill
animals in like programming
when in programming you know like
there's a funny way to kill anything you
just go over the top with it but
actually to do it I'm not in like I
wouldn't I don't see anything suffocated
unless it's the person that would go
around suffocating something then you
they blow a constrictor or serial
killers I don't mind seeing those things
suffocated but uh I am a uh as much as I
am a carnivore I do love animals yeah
there are some that I could kill I think
yeah have you have you watched that
video of a of a snake trying to swallow
a goat
like watching a like a snake like
literally hold an entire goat inside of
its body and figure out how to process
it was it trying to get his picture on
the wall
at the reptile restaurant I did got it I
know you watch [ __ ] like that's the kind
of dumb [ __ ] I would watch a guy one
time
it was so bad he got one he imported
some [ __ ] snake I don't know what
part of the web he was on but he got
like some anaconda or some [ __ ] and he
he put a goat in the cage with it and
the Goat had no idea what it was so it
walked up and sniffed it and this thing
just grabbed it and choked it and the
guy was going like I want watch its leg
watch his leg right here this is when
it's close to the end and I was like
this is the darkest [ __ ]
that and a guy fed a chick to a snake oh
yeah yeah totally going down as it was
going tweet
oh like from inside the snake's mouth
you could stop
dude yeah and I was just like I'm done
with this so that's what you're jerking
off to these days well you know you
your tolerance goes up after a while
yeah you got to keep raising the stakes
and find that limit
that's what it's like what Arnold used
to say every movie has to be bigger the
explosions have to be louder there has
to be more helicopters there must be
more there must be more chips chicks
being eaten by snakes yeah
I would vote for Arnold right now if he
ran for president I would vote for
Arnold
I think he's better than the other two
options
I love about CNN acts like they hate
Trump while they actively promote this
guy like they work for his social media
team they can't wait for him to come
back so they can spend four years with
their feet up going like I can't believe
this guy I mean what's he gonna do now
every day is like an easy news day
I have no interest in him I I watched
him so infrequently for the years that
he was President like I I didn't engage
with any Clips I don't watch the news I
can't watch the news I just I have five
minutes I'm like I'm bored I hate it I
don't wanna I don't think I've watched a
presidential speech since Bill Clinton
yeah
once they found out he was lying and I
just watched him go when he was going
like I did not have said he put his hand
like that so he was like wow okay you're
like I'm in now I mean I would I I
watched Obama I love I I loved Obama I
love Obama I love him
um he made me fall asleep every speech
not because I would think I was bored by
him but he I found him so comforting I
just found it very comforting hearing
him speak and it was wait he spoke he's
like yes
oh
he sounded like Jackie Mason doing the
aardvark now Jackie Mason was when I saw
that he died I he was born in this
country
like he was born in Ohio how is that how
is Jackie Mason how does that voice talk
like this like how is it possible that
that man was born because that's how
ethnic everything was he's probably his
parents were probably right off the boat
I was talking to somebody the other day
where where'd all the great ethnic names
like the kowalskis it was all there was
always like you know 10 skis right the
Polish kids all the you know the Italian
kids all the Irish kids and all that and
then somehow we all banged each other
yes and everybody got rid of the last
names because of all the hey how many
Italian Guys does it take to change the
light bulb that was like let's get rid
of all of this
it's true I there's a there's a
documentary in a book about this woman
Vivian Meyer who is a nanny in the 40s
and 50s but she's also a street
photographer and so she would take care
of her kids but she would just take
these like secret portraits of people on
the street and it's all pictures of
people in the midwest Milwaukee Chicago
all those cities in like the 40s 50s and
60s and you see their faces of the
people walking around Chicago and the
same thing you're like that is a Polish
face that is an Irish face that is a
like a Yugoslavian face like it was
before even the white people had started
to mix you know what I mean like hey
look at you and I and we're like I don't
know about you I assume like this is
just this is a hundred and thirty
percent Jewish this is like a hundred
and ninety percent Eastern European Jew
like I'm assuming are you all Irish or
just like you're like oh no I'm actually
not absolutely gone I'm mostly German
okay I never did one of those 20 three
isn't me no I don't want them we will
find a serial killer in my family and I
was raised not to be a rat so
I'm not gonna go in
and uh maybe it's me snake video with
the little little chick going down the
uh
yeah oh dude
uh so you're not yeah I could see the
German in you there there is that fiery
Hate in Your Eyes yeah there was nothing
about you that always bothered me you
know
there's something about you that would
make me feel like a snake with a sheep
in a cage all right let's if I can talk
about my people for a second please you
know that um
that famous Hitler footage I'm sure you
watch it all the time tonight
I can get off yeah
well there's the there's the classic one
where right before you know he was gonna
unleash his new ideas on the world sure
he is in this giant stadium and they
have like all like those little square
sections of troops and all of that and
they got all the the all their March the
Live Nation Nazi tour that they're gonna
go do this this Arena tour they're gonna
blow up the Arenas right so he gives his
host speech you know what I mean very
very Lewis Black yeah
before anybody takes that the wrong way
um
anyway
just to be clear for the record at the
end of the war is that that thing where
where the Allies blow up that concrete
swastika okay that's that same stadium
and
they never knocked it down
but they never like prepared it because
they don't if they knock it down they
make the guy a martyr because they're
trying to make it all go away in Germany
yes so my point is you can still go to
that place it's like Zeppelin
um Stadium or something you can stand
right there at your own risk because now
it's like almost like 100 years old and
it's all like falling down but I like
um you know I always saw all those World
War II movies and [ __ ] like that but
when you go over to Europe it becomes
like real especially when you see like
90 of the Cities the architecture is
from like the 1950s on and you're like
yeah because all their old stuff oh
that's right they're not load up they
blew the [ __ ] out of each other that's
right I I gotta say I respect Germany's
how they handled it they got real they
got real like all German [ __ ] they got
real serious about it and real like
genuine about it you know what I mean
they were like look we [ __ ] up
We're not gonna like we'll punish
ourselves like like a bad like a bad
little sub in a in a Berlin Sex Dungeon
they're like we deserve we we deserve to
be spanked with with like a metal battle
and we deserve this and we want it and
we need it and I think I respect that
like they don't like the U.S only watch
scat porn yeah
Nazis scat porn and uh and reptiles
killing chicks we're here with Nick
crawl everybody
who has a new comedy special little big
boy yeah and big mouth is coming out uh
end of the month end of the month and
then at the end of the month you think
you'll have time to go into your big
Hollywood pool
I will and then I'll get a bizarre
allergic reaction to it and then I'll
and I'll continue to be relatable to
people Beyond Myself do you explain your
latest IMDb credit instead of yelling
Cannonball before you go in
season five I go I go
Bill Burr Monday morning I'm Thursday
podcast on YouTube is it an IMDb credit
only God will know
hey you're a dad now man yes I am
I am your dad oh yeah times two two
young two young dads here just having a
combo two young dads two young Hollywood
dads about you know two men who made the
decision early in life to become fathers
uh who weren't into the Hollywood
question did you get your first
colonoscopy or have your first kid first
kid kid first still haven't gotten the
colonoscopy
I'm gonna stick the kid up there and see
what he finds
uh you know what it is is you like to
build tension so everybody's like that's
how you keep doing more seasons of Big
Mouth you just
wait and see how did your did you do
yours you've done yours
twice I'm a vet two tours
honestly other than the crap you have to
drink yeah easiest thing but here's the
thing don't drink the [ __ ] that they
give you ask say you want to pay for the
good stuff okay yeah they'll give you
the Red Label hold on you got the blue
label [ __ ] you want the high you want
the black they give you rock gut like
whatever the hell they gave me dude like
it was like three days and I thought it
was the procedure and I had to think
back like no it wasn't like that the
first time because the first time I got
the Johnny blue the first time okay oh
it was easy it was a freaking Cakewalk
but you were like like the first time
you were like a fancy Japanese
businessman and the second time you were
just like a a homeless guy getting a
plastic bottle whiskey the second time I
packed my own shoe
no Billy bounce for like three days no
seriously I was like
I was like uh and this is not the
procedure I'm not trying to scare people
away it was the rock got [ __ ] that they
gave me dude I was like walking it like
maybe like a 15 degree angle off because
I was just walking around my house and
you know
I I yeah so I think by the way if you
watch the special I don't think I need
any to drink anything I just think I
need to eat like one bowl of fettuccine
alfredo and I'll be cleared out for a
week like I'll just oh you're one of
those oh you're one of those people huh
yeah yeah I mentioned a Jewish right did
I did that come up already
about I didn't know you guys had
irritable bowel systems oh yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah it's now transferred to
my skin my skin is crazy my skin has
gone [ __ ] crazy in the last it's
always been bad but it's gotten crazy in
the last couple years allergic reactions
constantly face exploding you don't have
that
uh no this is just naturally how I look
I was saying my I had I was always like
Jews get eczema like and and it's like
they're like to remind us of the to
build the suffering to build the
pyramids the cracking and the Irish get
like rosacea it's like this like like
rage rage that lives inside it must come
out in this like blotchy and it's like
that's that's our that's what the two
groups and we and we end up all we all
end up in comedy we all end up at some
point doing in a writer's room
I I never you know what I I never knew
that that's that's that's why you gotta
you got to marry outside
for real you know it's like the uh the
royal family yeah I mean that's just one
of the weirdest collection of people if
you looked at them you would never think
that they were winning
you know what I mean that they were
living in palaces and all of that they
just look like I don't know they almost
look like they're from the past
they do because they are Princess Diana
I don't know where she came from she was
Royal but or she was fancy but from like
a royal yeah but she brought in my gut
is a she that she at some point was like
new money and they got to bring in a
couple hotties
like new money hotties into her into her
bloodstream that leads to her can you
imagine what they have in that family
you're talking eczema and rosacea what
if you all [ __ ] the same
puddle for 500 years or whatever they've
been doing
well
holy [ __ ] go back and look at the
habsburgs in like the 1700s they're
they're their their eyes were bigger
than their chins I mean they're they
have these like they truly were like
stomachless chinless
bizarre the truly most bizarre looking
people gold just spilling out of their
pockets
so rich and truly incapable of personal
or governmental rule like incapable of
controlling their own bowels and yet in
in control of millions of people it's
what happened to them
the Russian black them and bury him in
the uh they literally I think they they
[ __ ] themselves out of power uh I
believe I mean they might have gotten
all the way to World War one I mean
that's kind of where World War One
happens it's just like all these people
being like we need fascists we need
austro-hungarian we need like people to
get us out of these like inbred monsters
dictators
I think that's what happened I hope
that's what happened that was
fascinating
by inbred monsters who had all the gold
yeah so finally our eyes were bigger
than Nick chins can you develop that
it's not too late I mean it's I'm like
[ __ ] why didn't we do that for history
the world hey have you seen blonde yet
no is it good oh you got to take the
family
laughs do you watch it with the kids
I went to the premiere oh was it are you
in it no uh my buddy is in it but he
ended up not being there you're not
playing you're like I do think you're
one of those people they're like I think
Marilyn Monroe dated Ginger come on man
one of the hottest women ever yeah no
it's like birds playing uh you know he's
playing like Arthur Miller you didn't
know that bird got cast as Arthur Miller
by the way yeah
that guy killed it who is it the guy
playing Arthur Miller
do you know who it is probably the bad
guy the guy he played the piano we
kissed Halle Berry when he won the Oscar
oh
Brody I'm so I can't remember anybody's
name Adrian Brody was [ __ ] amazing in
that movie yeah good for him all right
everybody live reads you get to look at
the struggling face of a man who doesn't
like to read out loud look who it is
everybody it's Soul zip
recruiter you like that I walked off
um in case you didn't know okay she got
the cataracts there uh did you know
there are oh there are currently over
2.4 million podcasts in the world 1.7 of
them are on all things comedy including
the one you're listening to right now
and it takes a team of people to help
bring these podcasts together needless
to say then why would you say it uh
hiring the right people for these roles
is important and whether you're hiring
for a podcast or capital letters or uh
for your growing business there's only
one place that makes it easy
recruiter the devil Read and now you can
try it for free at ziprecruiter.com
ZipRecruiter uses its powerful
technology to find and match the right
candidates up with your job they should
do this as a dating site
you know Andrew
just you know go through all the dicks
you know and get through the to the the
one that you you want your vagina
Outsource it right Outsource it do it
for the day's too so everybody's happy
uh you can easily review these re
recommended re these recommended
candidates and invite your top choices
to apply
what are you basting it on looks
um additionally zip
yeah has a complete Suite of tools that
make it easy to filter review and rate
your candidates four to five employers
who post on Super Crew to get a quality
candidate within the first day it's
raining candidates over at your [ __ ]
Orange Julius so if you're a fan of the
podcast and you want to try zip
for free today you can uh you need to
remember our special URL
ziprecruiter.com once again that Zip Zip
recruiter
r-e-c-r-u-i-t-e-r.com
zip recruiter
the smartest way to hire
oh Andrew right into the camera like an
old school pitch man here oh and look
who it is one of our favorites one of
the most loyal people they have bought a
plate at the mm podcast running for
president
election the two thousand dollar plate
ever since we've been starting
stamps.com everybody
you know if you're a small business
owner
oh we're talking to little people now
sorry you know how important it is to be
ready for the insane holiday season and
if you haven't started preparing uh for
the chaos of holiday mailing and
shipping you're already falling behind
Santa's on his way and he doesn't have
your [ __ ] orders
um luckily stamps.com is everything you
need to make your life a whole lot
easier oh a small business Andrew elves
that's what they're talking about oh I
think oh Kris Kringle wrote this one
look that's the name he gives to the
cops
Kris Kringle uh luckily stamps.com has
everything you need to make your life a
whole lot easier it's the 24 7 post
office that you can access from anywhere
no lines no traffic no hassle do you
have insomnia would you like to be
getting things done when you don't
[ __ ] sleep
what if you had a Post Office right at
your fingertips just like Santa Claus
you've heard me talk about stamps.com
they've been sponsoring the show for
over nine years and if you haven't tried
it [ __ ] you waiting for stamps.com is
your One-Stop shop for all your shipping
and mailing needs a stress-free solution
for every small business
usestamps.com to print your postage
wherever you need wherever you do
business all you need is a computer and
a printer get ahead of the holiday chaos
this year get started with stamps.com
Jesus Christ it just keeps going sign up
with the promo code for a special offer
that includes a four-week trial plus
free postage and a free digital scale no
longer no long-term commitments or
contracts just go to stamps.com click on
the microphone at the top of the home
page and then the answer enter the code
burst so I get credit
uh and I can go buy some cigars uh get a
four week trial free postage and a
digital scale at stamps.com thanks to
stamps.com for sponsoring the show and a
special shout out Andrew too
fine ass cigars Finance cigars in
Phoenix Arizona if that Cardinals game
is too loud and you want to leave at
halftime that's the place you want to go
they treated me like gold it was awesome
thank you to them thank you to
stamps.com and thank you for listening
and watching and God bless America but
only this country because I'm patriotic
let's live stream this you watch the
movie and I sit here and watch you react
to it no no no I'll tell you what I've
been watching I watch uh people power
washing their driveways and walkways
yeah I got a ridiculous amount of
satisfaction of that I'm also watching
this guy who does these uh
um I don't know what you call him like
he finds these cars these great cars
that have been sitting in a barn and
like rats have gone in there and built
nests and [ __ ] and pissed on everything
and he just goes to work and all he does
is wash them
oh my God it is so satisfying to when
you get to the [ __ ] Wheels with that
thing and yes he's measuring like the
paint and everything I watched that and
then I've been watching um
I started watching Martin Sheen
um masterclass made for TV movies
Gus Martin Sheen
well I watched the first one I said I
liked it and then this buddy of mine
goes dude he did like six of those four
or five of them during you know the lean
years you know defeat his family and
before he did Apocalypse Now and I
watched one called The California Kid
hour and 10 minutes
the perfect one for anything
more
and uh a young Nick Nolte it was great
so this is so this is pre-apocalypse now
not post because like it's it's not like
like he almost he has like a heart
attack at 31 doing Apocalypse Now on
cocaine and then comes back and does TV
movies this is this is before that he
did a movie called The Incident
which he played like a hoodlum on
um
on uh on a subway train it is kind of
funny him like like Beau Bridges is in
it young Boba is super young it's in
black and white and if you haven't lived
in New York what's funny is the amount
of time between subway stops where all
of this stuff happens and like and then
the next stop but it is you know you can
see who I was an independent movie they
just said it on that then he did one
based on this real life serial killer he
was doing like all of this sort of
Darker things and then he got into the
the TV movies and I'm just starting to
kind of learn about his career but I
like going back and watching those old
things because I like looking at the
cars it's not all the noise of today so
that's why I don't I don't know uh I I
know some stuff about what's going on
you know plenty of stuff although you
know the bills came back and beat the
Ravens yesterday I I know what's going
on you know about that but I mean it's
like I'm like Bill I can't believe you
don't know Big Time current stuff you've
got a Primus poster and a Charles
Bronson poster behind you the I stand by
both of it absolutely that is no uh
that's the French death wish
um
[Music]
that's what I've been doing I'm learning
how to speak French really yep you have
an insatiable brain
what are you talking about yeah I'm
sorry that might not be right for your
brand bill I mean compared to you
and now I'm power washing other people's
driveways because I found the best one
and I'm studying Charles Bronson you
know no I'm just running from the demons
in my head you on the other hand when I
did the Nick Kroll Show you were on that
right I was on it
there you go [ __ ] sat there one time
and basically knew the entire you knew
you knew the history of Hollywood the
way I know like 70s NFL starting
quarterbacks oh you were going Studio
heads producers
one I'm just gonna throw out the movie
you tell me the Scandal behind it okay
let's see all right we're gonna try this
I won't be able to try to stump the
eczema guy all right
you take away his steroid creams his
topical steroid creams that's what you
do I've been there we've all had to take
a steroid cream here there
um
the getaway the getaway oh that's uh
you know more about Steve McQueen uh my
God this okay I don't know if this is
the right timing but I'll guess Steve
McQueen has started [ __ ] Ali McGraw
and uh and he's taking her away from uh
Robert Evans who's like nose is
collapsing at the age of 51 from the
amount of cocaine he's already done and
uh any and and and he gets away
Steve McQueen gets away and he did a
cool car that you that you fetishize
actually not cool cars because he's
doing the getaway so he like takes off
in a [ __ ] station wagon Woods
paneling and then they feel something
else like a four door sedan oh um so it
isn't that and just because I'm into
cars I don't fetishize it just because
you're not a car guy what do you got you
got some EcoBoost something or whatever
this I have another guy for a minute I
had a Prius I love that car I had a
previous for a minute I still like I I
my aunt has it now I drive it it's the
loosest drive in America dude I met so
many chicks in that Prius oh man you got
no idea that's something that's never
been said yeah I would just have to
drive down the street
and stop at a stop sign the second I
heard that engine turn off they were
like who is this guy who is that from
the future
uh I had a Prius you want to hear my
cars you want to hear my evolution of
cars
can I guess them sure please what year
did you start driving oh from back then
in 95 90 90 95 95.
Eastern Jewish eczema
95 so I figured the car is like
you were Irish should be at least seven
years old but your Jewish so say it was
about three years old Bingo bam three
years old
that's a 92. I'm gonna say you had a
used Nissan
uh I I appreciate you saying that it was
a it was my it was my mom's Volvo that I
put a cigarette burn in the first day I
drove it right on the little badass huh
do you have on your black leather jacket
yeah that was I wish picking up the
sheriff's daughter at the Bobby sock no
me you know me a greaser a greaser in a
[ __ ] Volvo always I'm just picturing
your hair all greased back with the
yamaka on it oh my God
yes absolutely just pretending to be
Duty doesn't that movie need to be made
yeah
I got the Jewish gang movie that needs
to be made oh I'm here I'm in the Purple
Gang
oh what's this I need more people gang I
didn't know that that was those were
Jewish gangsters
all that Godfather good good Fellowship
every Jew every Jewish family wants to
be like you know the Jews used to be the
boxers and they were the gangsters you
know what I mean it was like a it's a
real thing like we used to be tough at
one point we were the immigrants and we
were tough do you ever have they CA
you've gotten castles or not like a
gangster like an Irish gangster or
something
dude no [ __ ] who gives a [ __ ] that's
been done a million times nobody's no
one's shown you guys it's the Good
Fellas
true there was I mean I guess you got
Meyer Lansky you know what's his face
you do the voice over doing the Jackie
Mason impression ever since I could
remember I always wanted I can remember
it
I like to kill people
I respect rage such rage we would kill
everybody you know um this wonderful
woman I was dating a long time ago of
course I [ __ ] it up because she was
wonderful and I wasn't and uh she took
me on my birthday for my birthday to go
see uh Jackie Mason live on Broadway
dude he [ __ ] murdered he did an hour
of stand up took a break and came back
and did another 45 Jesus yes murdering
was he doing crowd work was it all just
material it was all material and he was
he he he what he would he had very like
economical movement because even by then
I mean he lived to be like in his 90s so
I saw him he was in his 70s so it was
funny when he would do like his little
little he'd always do like something
like that like joking around about
Gentiles dude
it was a chair now it's a toilet
he he was just his [ __ ] was like who is
he making fun of he was making fun of
like but he made fun of Democrats
Republicans like topical stuff old
school [ __ ] just a master I'm so I'm so
happy that I I got to see him I never
got to see him I if you go back this is
a separate but I went back and watched
uh back to school
Rodney Dangerfield have you watched that
movie recently it's not even acting he's
just doing stand-up yes exactly like
he's sitting there and they're like the
woman who she just passed away who was
hot lips in the original Mash movie
she's like you know she's the older
teacher who he like and she's like
Thorson you're fascinating he's like
that was so fascinating you know like
he's just immediately just doing it's
not acting at all he's just doing
material
okay
he flunk him and everybody around him is
just like it's it's as if he's having a
normal conversation it's so funny you
know what I love when he's acting too he
still has his restless leg syndrome he's
still doing the uh this guy's gonna do
that what I gotta think
s
God living the dream living when we uh
I did this movie with Pete Davidson a
few years and part of the wrap party we
went over his place and we watched easy
money it was one of my favorite parties
and everybody just sat there just dying
laughing first of all
the move you know in the first 10 pages
you kind of love they don't do that
until 45 minutes into the movie like you
don't even know what the [ __ ] movie's
about for 45 minutes other than you
laughing
um and it has Joe Pesci's in it uh
um um oh what's his face um he passed
away uh oh I'm gonna kill myself not
remember Taylor Negron Taylor negrons in
it oh yeah
you're the man
I meet Taylor Negron first time I ever
meet tiller I go in for an audition to
be on uh Curb Your Enthusiasm this is
years ago I was like it was I just
gotten an agent I was so excited that I
was gonna maybe you know it's like going
to audition for curb and that it was to
play like an a feat uh waiter you know
like a which is the nice way of saying
like uh a fish uh gay like they just
couldn't they weren't gonna say it so I
go in for the Edison the last minute
they're like waiter oh yeah they were
going deep on that show gay waiter and
then they were like
um and at the last minute they're like
oh and maybe it should be like foreign
you know when I get there they tell
before I was like okay I can do that
okay I walk right before me Taylor
Negron walks in and like they all know I
mean he was on Seinfeld he goes in and
the whole room's like and just keep
crushes like you can hear it from
outside the room he just crushes and
then I go in and it was I mean it was
just like they were like hi nice to you
know what I mean and that was that but I
was like of course
we've already cast this role greeting
yes yes that's known as we're just gonna
do the first scene yeah
yes for those of you not as business
that's what they do like prepare scenes
you know three scenes and blah blah but
I used to get that all the time when
they would just see me when I would walk
in because back then you had black and
white uh headshots and moose was in and
I had moose in my hair so my hair kind
of read Brown yeah yeah you know and my
agent wasn't going to tell them so
anytime I went in there if it was like
occasionally I would go in for a lead
um I'd be like they just don't pick a
redhead male Elite and I would walk in I
would see it in their face and I was
always like okay we're just just let's
just go to uh let's just do great let's
just do Scene Three we're a little
behind yeah we know we know what you can
do let's just and I was just saying we
just need you to you know we just need
you to see you drink the coffee and
we're good actually we don't even need
to get audio on this we just need to see
you drink it I don't know if you got the
rewrites but the character is now
walking out that door
and you're like they don't cast redheads
and then you turn that on and it's
Caruso and NYPD Blue you're like oh he's
the guy he's he's not that broke open
shut when his movies didn't work
he crushed NYPD Blue and then he made
really good movies like Jade and and
they just didn't hit and then all the
Hollywood I felt was like that's right
that's right you almost albino you get
back go back in your closet go back in
your closet but you don't tan that is
the dream you don't get the gun you
don't get the girl talk to the guy who
does but absolutely it's a better place
to be talking to the guy who does uh the
guy who does it's it's none of those
guys it seems exhausting seems
exhausting to be that guy oh number one
in the call sheet no that's not what you
want to be no I had somebody a long time
ago told me he goes you want to be about
eight eight or nine in the call sheet
you got enough lines where you're not
going to get cut out but you don't have
to work every day and you're on location
you can go around town check it out get
something to eat I'm not working today
hey I'm working two days I'm off for a
week oh go to the gym live a nice life
yes
I mean
I've always wanted a second family
family in Wilmington North Carolina
uh yeah it is it's it's true it's like
you see those guys who are number one
you're like how you doing they're like
good I uh I've been on for 70 days
straight and then uh
would you depressed horn I can't eat at
a restaurant and uh uh everyone hates my
new girlfriends so uh things are good
things are really good
nightmare I just read a book about
Wilmington North Carolina really what
was it about the the port what was it
about uh it was about uh this this thing
they did in the late 1800s it's not good
for tourism
uh it's called well Wilmington's lie the
Insurrection of 1892. it's actually a
it it makes now it makes a lot of what's
going on
you understand like how the [ __ ] did we
get here why are we all yelling at each
other why don't we like you know this is
stupid why why are we all yelling each
other and these eight [ __ ] are you
know treating us like little marionette
puppets and it's just kind of all
I I highly recommend it I actually I
don't read dude you you wouldn't know
this about me I don't read so uh
very busy watching power washing videos
how do you have time to read I read
books I read like four pages every night
before I go to sleep that's what I
that's it's it's that's how I fall
asleep as I read like a few pages of a
book and it means I read like four books
a year but I don't read during the day
because I will fall asleep immediately
uh kind of a good thing you know what's
funny I discovered coffee this year I
mean I knew it was out there but I
finally started drinking it
and uh
now I'm just kind of realizing that it's
better to just take a nap
than to drink coffee well then to trick
your body into thinking that it isn't
tired like it wakes you up it's like no
it isn't I guess it blocks
but it oh dude it tastes so [ __ ] good
dude wait how do you make it to 38
uh and not drink coffee
38 in the business the old David tell
Joe
um
because my dad used to my dad used to
drink it and he would leave it and leave
like this much and he and I would come
by an hour later and I would drink cold
like 1970s instant coffee I'm like this
is insanka drinking cold sink my parents
were Folgers they had the flavor of
Christmas in there yeah
which turned out to be I'm sure like
turned out to be like like ceiling
installation like fiberglass to open up
the throat porch there's a special this
is from the factory yeah that's
basically that just fell in so they got
ah what do we do yeah or in the public
their favorite crystals and then that
just opened up all of the so that the
coffee could enter the bloodstream
faster and they're like what a Dream
well that's like uh
you know this is scary and also makes me
want to try it just for the buzz chewing
tobacco oh yeah had like microscopic
pieces of glass to cut the inside of
your your mouth so the tobacco would go
like right to your brain you never I
thought you drive them stock cars faster
hanging you never you never packed a lip
you never did uh oh I just I I was
afraid of getting cancer and all that
but I I'll be honest with you I thought
that chewing tobacco was the coolest
[ __ ] thing everybody in baseball did
it
um all the badasses in my town did it me
too masses in my town they got the good
looking chicks they dipped and they
played hacky sack it's a weird
combination but there was a moment where
hacky sack was not a hippie thing no it
was cool and those guys and they're all
doing great now I'm assuming right
as far as I know one of the guys who was
the best at it I just ran it to him when
I was uh I was torn none of them where
the [ __ ] I was at but he came by it was
this this oh this is actually cool story
he was this [ __ ] like one of the best
class clowns I ever met in my life and
he was in my division in eighth grade he
called him divisions like it was Army
whatever and
um
that was the fastest school year
of my childhood that guy made me laugh
so hard it was like I just I I put my
head down started laughing and I woke up
it was already April did not do well
that year it was like he was just a
[ __ ] and I don't know how he just he
was however he was funny totally just
connected with me and he just made me
laugh my ass off and I uh yeah recently
he just came out to a show and typical
you know he didn't remember that he was
I didn't think I was that funny I was
like dude you were [ __ ] hilarious
and and he didn't remember he doesn't
remember himself what did your publicist
just text you do you have to get off
this thing no I'm trying to return I'm
I'm I'm I'm I've come back to LA and I'm
trying to connect with a baby uh rental
equipment uh you gotta power wash your
baby I rented a high chair in New York
and now I'm and now the guy's trying to
pick it up from the apartment that I was
at and so I was I I was getting like 15
calls in a row and I'm like who's
[ __ ] won't stop calling then I'm like
oh it's someone trying to I'm trying to
get get a baby chair back
pretty sexy stuff yeah that is not my
agent it was some guy being like I want
my [ __ ] high chair back you piece of
[ __ ] what are you and I gonna work
together again
let's see well I want uh let's see I
wanted you on History of the World you
were busy making your movies it done
where uh all we have to do is is score
it and put the color on it and we're
done uh just get rid of give it some
highlights let's just do it we'll see
what America thinks of it I think I want
a little judge we're gonna we love it
Bill the Rev everyone loves it
there's been a focus group we're
wondering if you need to be bald in this
one so we're wondering what it would
cost to paint in just painting some hair
we'll do it real quick it'll just be
like 72 quick sessions you can still see
your family still see your family
everyone can come by set and see you
um
I want to do I want to do anything with
you I you know I I'm I'm down what do
you what do you I mean like uh what do
we do I don't know what to do now
because I'm done that's all right
there's something uh
there's a guy oh I gotta remember this
guy there's a guy that if the two you
got on screen maybe there wouldn't be
enough [ __ ] room with both of your
talents I got to send you this is this
guy that I follow
oh what the [ __ ] is his name because I
really want to give him a shout out I'll
text it to you okay he yeah
all of that [ __ ] where like he'll like
he's like in drag or he'll do like you
know you can make like yourself have
like a little face like all that Kyle
Dunnigan stuff yeah he's completely away
from what Kyle does and and he yes is
this Brian Jordan Alvarez yes yeah that
dude's [ __ ] funny that [ __ ] guy so
funny
and slashing is my life sang that for a
week yes
he's like I stay home and do my music my
wife she is going for the day he's so
like a random laugh he would want the
water one some lake or something he goes
that kills me every time
do you think if you had started now
you'd be making those videos
you know what I mean like an Instagram
guy like you would be one of those guys
doing the videos
yeah I wouldn't there's a whole bunch of
[ __ ] like a lot of sketch stuff and
characters and all that stuff that I
just never did because I I got into like
stand up but
um
I had never seen and when they and when
they called your name
and you said
I asked for almond milk
it was I was so blown away that the the
humility that you had when you screamed
at that poor moment behind the camera
I'd see you around but then I saw you at
it it really changed how I wanted to do
comedy which I saw you would crash test
which was disease's show back at UCB
this is like you know 15 years ago in
New York and you were like and this was
at a time where I was like oh the alt
guys are over here and the club guys are
over here and I watch you come in to
crashes and I watch you [ __ ] Crush in
one in a hipster audience because in my
mind it's like oh you don't like the
club guys killed the clubs but they
can't [ __ ] crush it and you you guys
hated us well you guys hated us no no no
no no no no no no no no
but I wouldn't even tell you guys that
because I wasn't even around I wasn't in
the mix you guys you guys you guys would
do interviews and say we're not in the
clubs doing airplane material getting
ready for a [ __ ] Conan set you guys
are hammerness I wasn't doing interviews
yet I was dying to do interviews I
wasn't anywhere near him so but I but it
was there was this sort of we had we
were after a while we resented you guys
because all the industry went there but
initially
initially the way it was sold this was
initially it was Club Comics doing it
they created the scene but that second
wave they were the ones that came in
like they were the wine tasters of
comedy and that their [ __ ] um
when it became
except when you did a benefit then you
guys were real nice to us club guys and
all said you had to get out of there
because you didn't want to go on after
us that's the truth so I again I wasn't
there yet I was just watching those guys
you were in the tower you were taking
orders go ahead I was I was just
watching waiting just waiting yes I
could see the smoke uh but I couldn't so
so I but I remember watching you [ __ ]
Crush at a hipster show and I was like
oh okay I gotta go to the club I got I
was like that was when I was like oh I
gotta go to the clubs I gotta learn how
to make everybody laugh
if because Bert I was and I you know and
and now I'm doing three nights of femway
and I gotta thank you for that because I
remember that's all true that's all
because I remember that I was like I
remember thinking when you would come up
this is one of the few guys that gets it
because I felt like when I was doing
um certain comedy clubs in most of the
alt rooms I felt like the crowd were you
like a radio station like I performed a
white people from ages 18 to 24 that are
into superheroes and then there was
another club that I did where it was
just like uh this Boston club that I
used to do
and um you know before that the comedy
addict no I can't no so many of them
went under it was like a one of those
satellite rooms and there was just
something about that area
that everyone was just so from that area
so if you somehow could just shrink your
act into the one block that they all
lived on you were a God and they would
carry you out of the place but the
second you you went to the next town
over you you might as well have been
speaking another language or whatever so
it's a but it was a really it was a
super useful lesson to me and I so I uh
I appreciate that and I've literally
watched and it it's the proof is in the
pudding you [ __ ] kill for everybody
everywhere and uh so I think jokes are
relatable and I'm trying to get there
man you know what it is I gotta I I I
remember this Nick everybody has to [ __ ]
so that's where you start your act from
you buddy I'm gonna I'm gonna I'm gonna
ask you I'm gonna ask you to watch my
special where I tell them three to four
[ __ ] pants stories uh trying to trying
to to try there's a lot of this about
your irritable bowel system it's about
it yeah it's about I mean it's about my
it's just about [ __ ] my pants a
bunch I [ __ ] my pants a bunch as an
adult irritable bowel system is when you
get hair plugs for your ass crack
it's a system it's a system of butt
plugs not butt plugs for sexual pleasure
but also a client and then you drop your
hands in the end I'm not just the
president of this butt plug this butt
plug system we've got Jason Alexander
we've got all I remember I'll say this
real quick before we wrap this up here
um
and you have gone over
I am enjoying you good it's okay because
whenever I say I got to wrap this up
when you were [ __ ] when I went to do
your show Crow show I forget the name of
that lunatic character that you were
playing with with the [ __ ] Dr Armand
you oh my god Dr Arman and I I came out
all right done a little hair makeup and
I came out and I saw you standing you
were already in character I just
remember like this guy is out of his
[ __ ] mind and this is gonna be yeah
well you and I used to act out all the
words that you said that we're done
picked that he had well because he
couldn't move his face because he had so
much work done so the only way I could
get expression out was to do everything
he did it was a he was a plastic surgeon
for dogs who then got caught in like a
staircase True Crime world and you were
the cop who was on him yeah he murdered
his wife I still think he was guilty you
still think he murdered his wife all
these years are you that's how much you
commit to the role well that's why he
had the plastic surgery I felt because
he didn't want to betray his guilt and
he wanted to have the perfect Poker Face
where I couldn't tell if he was innocent
or guilty
that's how deep Bill Burr goes as an
actor people don't realize this hey man
it wasn't just a sketch to me no it was
that was a real crime I'm still alive
all right by the way that's the way to
do it that's the way you got to do it
you got to go all in all in all the time
it and it works it works that's right
another great memory is I I worked with
Ron Howard's Howard's father on one of
the sketches yes he told me what it was
like to work on Cool Hand Luke
Jesus he was one of the eggs huh
foreign
get mad at them eggs all right Nick
Kroll everybody check out his new
stand-up special and The Runaway hit big
mouth on Netflix I love you brother I
hope we get to at least hang out or
something and debate all comedy versus
Club comedy okay hi buddy good to see
you both thanks for having me
hey what's going on it's Bill Byrne it's
the Monday Morning podcast of Monday
October 6
2014. hello it's me
I haven't podcast for a long long time
actually it was last Monday in the
morning
[Applause]
it's important to be
hey what's going on how are you
um as you can tell I screamed and yelled
all this [ __ ] weekend and that only
means one thing oh Billy red face had a
stand-up gig
if you're new to my podcast well why is
your voice get raspy after you have a
show because I don't know how to write a
joke
so what I have to do is I have to screen
my ideas I ask I have to use the f word
right and left and left and right you
know and then make silly faces
I was actually up in San Francisco if
you're going to San Francisco
um
I'm gonna put some Flowers in Your Hair
yeah and some changing your pockets for
the [ __ ] 9 000 homeless people they
have up there
Jesus Christ just inundated with them
you know what's great it was towards the
end of the month and two great things
wait that doesn't make sense the
beginning of the month was back when you
wouldn't see the homeless people in San
Francisco because they actually gave
them a stipend
which was a you know a little bit of
money
so they could get him off the [ __ ]
streets
you know like these [ __ ] people know
how to handle money they know how to
handle money they would they wouldn't
have been homeless
hey this guy sucks at math I know let's
give him an algebra book all right see
you fella good luck with that
we're not going to teach you on any
level
that's not even true that's even worse
that that example doesn't even make
sense that wasn't the correct example
because if somebody sucks with money and
you just give them money
you know somebody sucks at math you give
him an algebra book they could actually
learn about math
how do you just give somebody some math
give them a bag of numbers
whatever you want you know what I'm
trying to say
all right and even if you don't I don't
know that you don't because you can't
call into this show
all right the phone lines the
non-existent phone lines cannot light up
trying to write down Alabama so I don't
forget to talk about them this week
Alabama
the dream ended this weekend
um anyway so I was up there in San
Francisco
and I was working Davey's Symphony Hall
and I had a great time
and you know my favorite part of the
[ __ ] weekend was Jay lawhead Jason
lawhead Rose Bowl tailgate Legend
Jason lawhead uh before he's going to
bring me out
he's like
he's like what do you want my she turned
on the [ __ ] air conditioning can you
hear that stupid thing rattling
I tried to tell her you know you try to
tell your wife you don't want something
and what do they [ __ ] doing anyways
because they think that they know I know
what's good for him
I know it's good from hang on I gotta
shut this [ __ ] thing off
all right I'm back I'm [ __ ]
believable
swear to God you know for all that [ __ ]
moaning and complaining they do on all
those those [ __ ] Yap yapping shows
there you know I know what's what's
better than one woman running her yap
well let's get three others and have
them all sit around with their shoes
you know
yep yap yap and about all the [ __ ]
[ __ ] that's going on are those shows by
the way the view the talk and all those
are those like women's versions of like
a guy watching those stupid pregame NFL
shows
you know rather than for broads you got
[ __ ] four Meathead guys in their
suits
you know it's it's a it's a bubble
screen
John Gruden says [ __ ] bubble screen
one more goddamn time this [ __ ] week
I got it it's a bubble screen
there's a screen and there's a bubble
and he's got an option and they're gonna
[ __ ] have the lineman go this way and
see what the doors are think it's a run
okay you're gonna use this option over
here if he wants to we could throw it
back again
keep the [ __ ] ball and you can try to
run it but the key is the quarterback
has to understand where to make a
decision to either release the ball or
to hold on to it I'll tell you what when
you when you start doing something like
that that's when good things will be
happening in the National Football
League
um
so just all of that dumb [ __ ] that I
just [ __ ] said that I don't need to
know
I don't need to know any of that I don't
need to know what a [ __ ] bubble
screen is to watch a goddamn game it's a
hot read it's a hot read yeah it comes
up on the line it's a [ __ ] hot is it
a hot read
it's a hot breed
I can't just be he goes up to the line
and if he sees something yeah let's
[ __ ] do it and if he doesn't let's
just stick with the play it's a hot read
on a bubble screen in a cover too
Tango Sierra Alpha
um
anyway so I'm up there in San Francisco
and for once
every I was up there Friday Saturday and
Sunday and it was beautiful weather
every single day 85 Degrees 80 degrees
global warming at its finest right this
is how miserable the [ __ ] weather is
in San Francisco they
um
most places don't have air conditioning
because they don't [ __ ] need it
they're in California and they don't
need air conditioning
all right why don't you wrap your little
[ __ ] podcasting listening brain
around that all right
um
actually when you think about it
California goes pretty much almost the
entire Coast
of the West Coast of the continental
United States the lower 48 anyways
so I guess at some point
right you got to be as far north as like
Wyoming
I know they get snow
but I know people in Wyoming gotta have
[ __ ] air conditioning
does anybody in Wyoming listen to this
are you out there right now on a horse
just sitting there staring at cattle
trying to figure out what's out there
that keeps killing one of your calves
every [ __ ] eight days
sitting there arguing with you buddies
look at the bite my little bite marks
there that ain't no [ __ ] coyote
coyote can't kill a [ __ ] cow you dumb
son of a [ __ ] you know where you get
that from you get that from your mother
I know she was [ __ ] dumb the moment I
looked down at her boots all right but
her tits were hanging out my favorite
song was on the jukebox so I said [ __ ]
it I ain't got nothing in the back of my
truck I lay her down there stick my
Coors Light on her forehead and I'll
I'll tell you what
I'ma put it right in there
the next thing you know she starts
calling me up on my CB come in there
good buddy my stomach's getting bigger
and I ain't been eating [ __ ] I think I'm
pregnant and I'm like well ain't this a
son of a [ __ ] all right unless Jesus is
coming back again as a baby it must be
mine so here you are here you are
half a [ __ ] stupid telling me that a
goddamn coyote killed this [ __ ] cow
then I'll tell you one more time that it
was a pack of wolves and if you keep
having that dumb look on your face I
swear to [ __ ] God imma shoot you on
my own goddamn property is that
understood
I'll quit you crying you're just like
your mother
if you're out there in Wyoming
all right
yeah I know you got air conditioning
you might not have teeth but I know you
have aircon I'm sorry why do I keep
doing this you know what's funny about
Wyoming
a lot of it is [ __ ] rich people
who've gone out there and bought
property like Ted [ __ ] Turner
like Ted Turner I think can ride his
horse
from uh the border of
the United States and Mexico and ride
his [ __ ] horse all the way up to
Canada at least that's his goal without
ever not being on his own property
you know and like most driven men at any
point does he even think about the
[ __ ] horse that does not want to walk
gallop
or trot
all the things that horses do [ __ ] in
public it doesn't want to do
it doesn't want to do that
it never wanted you on its back to begin
with why the [ __ ] would it want you on
its back
Jesus Christ you're Ted Turner you can't
afford a robot horse
huh
with your Jeopardy mustache
haven't said all that great investment
I got to tell you that Ted Turner you
know when it comes to money he
understands it
'll be great if Ted Turner just walked
up to a homeless guy
and rather than explain money to him
just started yelling at him about money
dressing them down
you know like a head coach
pissed off at his [ __ ] starting
quarterback who's making a bunch of
mistakes
right and his job is like right on the
bubble you know if he just came walking
up to the homeless guy
throws a [ __ ] clipboard down at his
feet after he sees the guy buy some
[ __ ] heroin with a bunch of nickels
not a [ __ ] I don't got into me to
yell again all right I'm sorry I just
set up a total comedy scenario and now
I'm bailing all right I'm [ __ ]
rolling right out of it you know why I
can't do a Ted Turner I don't even know
what he sounds like
I just when I picture yeah my picture
Norm Macdonald when he used to imitate
that guy who used to hold the pen and
run for president Bob Dole Dole
that's how I picture Ted Turner talking
Ted Turner talking a new talk show
he's so [ __ ] Rich he doesn't have any
gifts
um all right so anyways I go up to San
Francisco
and the weather's beautiful
and uh you know I got some family and
friends up there
we [ __ ] hang out
what do we do what do we do Friday night
oh went out to this unbelievable Italian
restaurant
and uh I actually have been craving a
pork chop
for a while
for years actually I'm not gonna lie to
you I gotta I got a great pork chop
um why does that word sound so annoying
pork chop
um at this restaurant out here in LA
and it was so [ __ ] unbelievably good
all right so unbelievably [ __ ]
tender
that
I came back like 10 days later going I
gotta get this pork chop again pork
chops and applesauce yeah let's that
swell right
Brady Bunch pretty much reference there
more chops and Ambush natural
um
and I [ __ ] I went back and they had
taken it off the menu
and then I ordered something else and it
sucked
in fact everything sucked
the offense sacked the defense sacked we
sucked
um the whole [ __ ] the whole meal
stunk
so
I went years just thinking about this
[ __ ] pork chop
waiting for the right [ __ ] restaurant
with the right level of quality of food
that if it was on the goddamn menu I was
going to order it there's not a lot of
play not a lot of nice restaurants
will serve you a [ __ ] pork chop
you know your choices are usually you
know steak
some sort of chicken fish
maybe lamb
all right they might do a pulled pork
ah they might do a pig ear [ __ ]
sandwich a brisket or whatever but to
try to get somebody to get to make a
[ __ ] pork chop
all right the way that your mother never
did because who's kidding who who's
kidding who
moms do not know how to cook pork chops
all right
they just take as my dad would say
Christ you cut the [ __ ]
right
they cook the [ __ ] out of it
which is very easy to do with pork I
don't know why but it's very easy for
that thing to taste like one of the
[ __ ] tiles that's on the floor you
catch it
um
so anyways I went to this restaurant
this Italian restaurant that had
homemade [ __ ] pasta one of my
favorites and I saw that pork chop and I
said [ __ ] that pasta
all right there Luigi you tell clemenza
in the kitchen I don't need his [ __ ]
pasta
all right I want
I want a [ __ ] pork chop so I ordered
this pork chop I got a side of pasta the
pasta was [ __ ] outstanding and I know
like most times most shows like Anthony
Bourdain would tell you what [ __ ]
restaurant he went to I don't do that
you know why because I want to be able
to go back there without standing in any
sort of a [ __ ] line
so why don't you go to San Francisco and
figure it out for yourself
that would be my cooking show do you
like how arrogant I am Anthony Bourdain
has this huge [ __ ] millions and
millions of fans watching this show I
just got you know I got a couple
thousand fans listen to this [ __ ]
thing and I want to make sure I I cannot
guys I can't say the names of things on
my podcast
the the the crush of people that will be
showing up
to get a [ __ ] pork chop
and goddamn
oh my God are you kidding me oh my God
are you kidding me
oh my God all right I thought the
[ __ ]
I just thought this whole [ __ ] thing
just shut off
when I set it back down I'm doing this
right as I woke up
do you know how many times that's
happened to me like I go to restart it
and then I [ __ ] riff for 20 minutes
and I look in the [ __ ] recorders off
and I'm like oh my God
just like I just said oh my are you
[ __ ] kidding I gotta do it all over
again I had that really funny character
from Wyoming I'll never be able to
Hillary um
I just [ __ ] panicked and you know
what that brings me to a [ __ ]
unbelievable story that I gotta talk
about later let me finish with the pork
chop then I'll do a little bit of
advertising all right that's your second
course all right and the dessert will be
my little [ __ ] story about panicking
that will not be enjoyable to listen to
it absolutely terrified me all right
so I ordered this [ __ ] pork chop
absolutely delicious
absolutely [ __ ] delicious
you know
and uh what was I talking about yeah and
I'm not going to tell you where I got it
Not only would I never tell you if I
know I can't even remember the name of
it so now I'm [ __ ]
I don't know who gives a [ __ ] you heard
me trying to remember the name of a
[ __ ] X-Men that's a goddamn zillion
dollar movie I'm gonna remember the name
of a a restaurant the [ __ ] was it called
there was a number in it I remember that
that Jesus Christ
this is when the cops would just put
away their little [ __ ] you know that
little pad that they write on
they'll probably have an iPad now
can you describe what he looked like I
don't know why don't you go [ __ ] look
at the security footage
we're in the middle of nowhere well
[ __ ] call up the drone company I'm
sure they were watching something
[ __ ] nerd weirdos jerking off to the
top of my head
[Music]
all right let's get let's do a little
bit of advertising here for this week
everybody all right
um no one
what is going on with this [ __ ] come on
Bill for Christ's [ __ ] sakes
all right I swear to God
me undies right me undies I swear to God
this is the name of a company meundies
everybody
it's unbelievable how putting on a great
pair of underwear changes your entire
outlook for the day
that is not a joke you know that feeling
of putting on that ratty old saggy
underwear
I want you to know the feeling of
wearing great fitting great looking
underwear that's cupping your balls
there
this is ridiculous you need to know
about meundies.com me undies has the
most comfortable underwear you have ever
tried on they fit perfectly they don't
ride up on you and they literally pull
moisture away from your skin gross
they pull moisture away from your skin
all day so you're cool all day long but
here's the thing they also make you look
great
they give you a package a nice profile
go to meundies.com and check out the
pics of all the different styles of
underwear oh I know I'm going to do that
I don't know about you guys and for the
ladies check out those hot looking boy
shorts
many women uh yeah nothing like
suggesting you might have a dick
uh men and women high quality materials
for your high quality materials if you
know what I mean the price glad you
didn't ask a fraction of what typical
high-end underwear designers charge
here I'll help you out go to
meundies.com
and get 20 off your first order twenty
percent off your first order when you go
to Mayon days uh Slash Burr and right
now you'll even get free shipping in the
US and Canada
well you know what I gotta go I gotta
see me undies
m e u n d i e s
dot com
let me check out me undies
does that chick of a dick
all right hang on
me undies men
yep those are underwear
uh men's pajama pants men's French terry
slim sweatpants
unisex French terry sweatshorts they got
boxer briefs they got trunk and they got
the men's brief
you know what I got to tell you those
things look comfortable as hell
I owe them apology
you guys got to go to me undies me
undies uh cup you [ __ ] balls
all right let's get back to the [ __ ]
podcast
um
all right where the hell are we
oh yeah so I go up to San Francisco and
I got this great pork chop and um
smoked a cigar at the top of one of
those goddamn Hills
and uh called it a night
and oh my God I almost forgot about the
[ __ ] steam room
I gotta tell you about the [ __ ] steam
room
I gotta make sure I remember to tell you
that all right so let's just get to the
show so I go over to uh uh Davey
Symphony Hall
beautiful venue bunch of people showed
up and uh so before I I go out on stage
or whatever before we start the show
Jason lockhead Goes hey Bill he's like
uh what do you want me to say about you
and I was like you know I'm gonna see
them on Netflix
Letterman and he goes you want me to
Hype the new special and I said yeah if
you don't mind doing that he said
absolutely when's it come out what's it
called I said it comes out December 5th
on Netflix and it's called I'm sorry you
feel that way
and he goes okay all right cool and then
five minutes later he goes hey what's
your special called again I keep
thinking why do I do this what it's
called I'm sorry you feel this way he
goes okay I got it I got it and I looked
at him I go Jay he's like what I go
you're gonna [ __ ] this up
and he goes no I'm not I'm a
professional and he laughs and he leaves
so he goes out he does his thing
he gets to his clothes and bit
it crushes right
and uh I'm like okay you know I'm in the
bubble I'm getting ready to get brought
out
so I'm ready to get brought up
and I'm waiting for him you know to do
his little fighting out of the Red
Corner he stands at five foot ten he
can't get a 10. he's got freckles on his
ass he is
the rating
right
um but he doesn't do that
he just starts talking
he finished his [ __ ] act like he
always does he kills like he always does
and now he's supposed to [ __ ] bring
me up and instead of bringing me up he
starts yammering all and on going you
know it's been great out here to be here
in San Francisco uh beautiful weather
today you know me and Bill were out
there uh
sampling some of the local fare
blah blah blah blah and he just starts
just not telling jokes not really
telling a story just sort of vaguely
describing the day
yeah I was about 82 degrees out there
barometric pressure
and I'm sitting there going what the
[ __ ] is this guy doing and then he just
goes all right you guys ready for the
man you came to see you now you know he
is uh
he's got a special coming out on Netflix
and then he just looks over at me and he
goes ah
he's like I can't remember what it's
called and then I [ __ ] died laughing
died laughing because then I realized
what he was doing he wasn't even talking
to the crowd he was just saying English
words that they'd understand is in his
brain he was going what the [ __ ] is it
called so I went out there
and for five minutes just trashed him
for saying sampling some of the local
fare
and looking back I should have trashed
the crowd for not immediately heckling
him for saying [ __ ]
sampling some of the local fair what the
[ __ ] does that mean do you realize what
a creepy
a creepy [ __ ] expression that is
sampling the local fair
anybody who just blew into town could be
talking about anything from getting
something to eat to being a [ __ ]
serial rapist and I was sampling some of
the local fare you know that's something
like Hannibal Lecter would say if he
[ __ ] took a bite out of your neck
um so anyways
so I went out there and I tried a bunch
of new [ __ ] and it seemed to work and
then we did uh
it was just it was just a perfect show
man that first show was just awesome
right not saying the second one wasn't
but I had such a funny moment
uh during the show where I'm in the
middle of my Act
and the Giants
you know they're in the playoffs
playoffs
and um
I'm in the middle of one of my jokes and
I have no idea what's going on
in the game
and all of a sudden this guy just yells
out in the upper deck he just goes
and the crowd just [ __ ] erupts into
cheers
so I immediately do the math I'm like
San Francisco Giants it's [ __ ]
October that's right I've been watching
some of the but it's the playoffs and I
was like oh yeah I can't get mad at that
I can't get mad at that you Giants fans
you want to be watching the games but
you [ __ ] bought tickets to my show
so you know you're going to do a little
multi-task in there so I said all right
two to one and I was like what inning is
it
and the crowd starts yelling you know
when a bunch of people are yelling and
you're standing up on stage it bound the
sound bounces off the wall behind you
and it can be very hard to understand
what people are saying so I was like
what inning is it they're like hey
I'm like what what is that hey Jay
oh my God I can't hear you and I go hey
Jay
I'm going 80 like eight
eighty come on what what and just
[ __ ] hold up your fingers and they
kept yelling out and it sounded like
they were saying eight I go you know
what it sounds like you're saying 18.
one inning just one person one person
was holding up seven fingers so I was
like the seventh
and they were like hey Jane
that's what it kept sounding like I kept
going it keeps sounding like you're
saying the 18th a minute 90 excruciating
seconds of this
until I find out they were actually
saying 18. it was the [ __ ] 18th
inning
the Nationals score to run in like the
third [ __ ] inning
to go up one to nothing
and then the Giants scored one in the
top of the ninth to tie it up or the
bottom of the ninth oh no top of the
ninth that's right it was in Washington
to tie it at one to one and then they
didn't score again until
the [ __ ] top of the 18th and neither
did the Nationals the Nationals went 15
[ __ ] Innings without scoring a run
the Giants
played a whole nother baseball game
before they scored another [ __ ] run
and uh
unfucking believable and you know what
it's you know if that happened
in the middle of July you'd want to kill
yourself but if it happens in October
it's unbelievable
you know for as much [ __ ] as people give
me as a hockey fan why do you watch the
regular season
it doesn't even count
everybody makes it but like four [ __ ]
teams it's like yeah but there's
exciting games
they're allowed to fight okay there's
great things that can happen you know
baseball on the other [ __ ] hand other
than the beginning in April where you're
excited because it's a new season other
than that I mean it's just it's [ __ ]
brutal
until you get to October
and I would put baseball playoffs right
up playoffs I put it up there with any
other [ __ ] playoffs
um I actually well I love October
baseball
um it's this is the best time of [ __ ]
year October uh playoff baseball
National Football League the National
Football League has been going on long
enough where you're starting to know
who's going to be competitive and who
isn't and then hockey's coming up and
then right after that basketball
it's unfucking believable
it's unbelievable my life is perfect
um
and I actually watched that first
um Cardinals Dodgers game I didn't see
game two I watched game one and I was
I am 100 convinced that Donnie baseball
is cursed
I mean they had their race
what's the guy car shot I don't know I
don't watch baseball I have no [ __ ]
idea and all I do is I I just keep
hearing about this guy that he's
basically having like a season better
than Pedro Martinez in like 1999 I'm
like I gotta watch this guy and uh
I start watching the game
and I know the Dodgers have this that
unbelievable right fielder he's like
[ __ ] Willie Mays on steroids not
literally steroids but you know people
are just bigger now
and uh so he gets drilled in the [ __ ]
arm when he's up there and I guess the
Cardinals were doing that [ __ ] last year
so all of a sudden the next guy comes up
their first baseman who's like my height
he gets in the face of [ __ ] some guy
named Benji I don't know anybody's name
anymore they start [ __ ] screaming at
each other
and uh I was I was totally hooked I was
into it the [ __ ] Dodgers were up six
to two
going into the seventh or eighth [ __ ]
inning
all right
I think Clayton Kershaw is the name of
the pitcher I have no [ __ ] idea but
now they all have beards and all that
crazy [ __ ] they all stole it from the
Red Sox who stole it from the homeless
guys right and uh
you know they got their [ __ ] ace
guy's got a was it six to one or six to
two it's got a four run [ __ ] lead the
goddamn game is over
all of a sudden he loads up the bases
there's a single six to three there's
another single six to four Donnie
baseball comes walking out like dude
what the [ __ ] are you doing and the
little bearded Wonder goes hey I may not
be able to grow a man's beard but I know
how to get out of this [ __ ] inning
all right I'm only at 100 pitches I won
the Cy Young Award I want every [ __ ]
award you can win as a goddamn pitcher I
got this Donnie and Donnie baseball
makes the right choice abso [ __ ]
lutely
this is the move to make
we gotta win game one we got to do it on
your arm right
[ __ ] comes up
this other [ __ ] dude who owns them
this is the worst [ __ ] Sports
coverage ever I don't know anybody's
name he [ __ ] hits a
a goddamn
double that just clears the bases
three run score
six to five six to six now it's six to
seven they're down by a [ __ ] run and
they got a man on second now Donnie
baseball comes out pulls this [ __ ]
kid brings in this [ __ ] palooka he
comes in serves up a [ __ ] meatball
and then to left center field and then
it turn again unbelievable right that's
gonna be the St Louis [ __ ] announcer
they scored two more runs it is now nine
to six
they started the inning six to two up
four [ __ ] runs with the greatest
pitcher of the last 15 [ __ ] years by
the end of the inning they are down by
three runs how does that happen
and you know how bad I'm rooting for the
Dodgers
to win there's so many teams that I love
this year Kansas City you gotta love
that they're back in it the Baltimore
Orioles you gotta love that they're back
in it
you know
and Don Mattingly you got to want that
guy to win a [ __ ] uh you know win a
ring and then he got the Giants
I mean you know they've just won two I
mean I like seeing a [ __ ] Dynasty
or whatever the [ __ ] they would be
called it's great right just a lot of
[ __ ] teams to root for and then
that's sitting there uh
suggesting that maybe the Cardinals are
stealing signs from second base and that
they have a reputation for doing that
and once I found out that's not illegal
it's like I [ __ ] love these guys even
if it was illegal that's the kind of
cheating that you gotta respect you know
if you can look over at your [ __ ]
neighbor's paper and they're smarter
than you are you know are you really
cheating are you just delegating power
um anyways I don't know what the [ __ ]
I'm talking about so I watched that
whole game
beside myself
I just can't [ __ ] believe it and the
thing about
Don Mattingly he's such a Class Act
and he just sits there expressionless
and you know it's just ripping his
[ __ ] heart out I want to see that guy
get a ring so goddamn bad if he doesn't
I would love to see either the Royals or
The Orioles because when I first started
watching playoff baseball it was always
the Royals it would always win the west
and they could not get past the Yankees
um
and then there was uh when did they oh
they finally got by him in 1980 and then
lost to the Phillies with Pete Rose at
first base dribbling the ball up to the
pitcher on the [ __ ] astro turf and um
and the Orioles
I I let's see I saw them win it in 83 in
uh the first World Series
well the Third World Series that I
watched 1979 the Orioles versus the
Pirates so I was hoping the Pirates
gonna win their one game playoff and
maybe I could have a rematch in 1979 and
then they'd bring back We are family
um sorry
um anyways
uh
so I watched that [ __ ] so that I'm I'm
rooting for uh Donny baseball so anyway
so I'm watching that [ __ ] then I go out
and I go do my show smoke a cigar and
one of the greatest things you can do
after you smoke your cigars besides take
a [ __ ] shower and gargle with
mouthwash for an hour he's still gonna
wake up with that taste in the back of
your throat so if you have access to a
steam shower you go down and you take a
St you take a steam and you [ __ ]
sweat out all the impurities
and um
and then you you you're good to go you
go out you [ __ ] jump at a cold shower
a lot of people don't know how to take a
[ __ ] Steam
you know they [ __ ] go into the steam
sweat their [ __ ] nuts off and then
they walk out and they stand there oh
God it's hot as [ __ ] and they just stand
there
and then they [ __ ] go back in and
then they come back out and then they go
I got one more session I mean they
[ __ ] go back in again morons
[ __ ] morons all right this is how you
take a steam you just stay in there for
like 10 minutes that's all you need and
as you're in there for 10 minutes be
wiping the the [ __ ] sweat off of you
your body is is when you mean you sweat
it's releasing toxins your skin is like
a sponge if you let it sit there on you
okay
you're gonna [ __ ] reabsorb some of it
as you're sitting there in the [ __ ]
steam shower these [ __ ] guys do that
then you're supposed to walk out of the
steam shower and immediately walk in and
take an ice cold shower immediately
so your pores stay closed and you wash
off as much of the [ __ ] toxins that
you sweat it out as possible and you
will feel like a [ __ ] million bucks
all right and all you need to do is just
be in the ice cold water for like you
know
whatever five six seconds
however long it takes you to [ __ ]
hose off your body and then you can turn
it on to an acceptable temperature and
then you're good to go and you always
wear flip-flops so you don't get [ __ ]
planters warts or athlete's foot or any
other [ __ ] awful bacteria that's
that's that's in the goddamn you know
thing there right so
um
anyways the [ __ ] uh
what was I gonna say so if we [ __ ] go
there there's no I I walk in one with
lawhead and I walk in to see if there's
anybody in the steam shower and I walk
and there's the uh the sauna which is
just the dry heat and I look in there
and there is this Asian dude completely
[ __ ] naked
okay he had the decency to put his arm
in front of his junk as I walked by kind
of like Burt Reynolds when he did the
[ __ ] uh
the Playgirl
whatever the the Playgirl centerfold or
whatever the [ __ ] he did
um so I'm like oh God a naked Asian an
Asian we got an Asian in there lion
and he's like and we just said I mean
he's sitting there butt ass naked on the
[ __ ] seat
that someone else has to sit on
[ __ ] unbelievable
so
me and law had you know because I was
walking in to make sure that the steam
was on
uh so then
we [ __ ] come walking back in and as
we walk back in the the naked Asian the
nation there is had gone into the shower
he knew to take the cold shower and he
just comes walking out
completely [ __ ] naked all right so
I'm laughing there's always the [ __ ]
naked guy all right
so then I uh
I open the sauna and no no no no no I
[ __ ] up as as we go that's right then
we go back to the lockers we change now
we're walking back and we're laughing
about the naked Asian dude and right as
we go to turn the [ __ ] corner
to go into the sauna like the [ __ ]
Truman Show four people walk in front of
us and go right into the sauna there's
this little [ __ ] I mean the steam room
it's this little ass [ __ ] steam room
and they all [ __ ] go in there and I'm
thinking oh man maybe maybe there'll be
enough room and I open the door and
they're all just [ __ ] sitting there
it's just a nice guy packed house
whatever these guys will just be in here
for 10 minutes so me and law had to go
back and we're just sitting there and
we're laughing about the naked Asian
dude right
um long story short these [ __ ]
jerk-offs are in this goddamn
uh steam room and they're doing that
[ __ ] where they're coming out so [ __ ]
hot and then drinking water letting it
all reabsorb
and then just going back in they're in
there for like a [ __ ] half hour so
finally me and Laura had it like [ __ ]
we got to go and look
you know we want to go watch the
football what the [ __ ] are we gonna do
you know what are our options you got
all [ __ ] 20 sweaty ball guys in there
or we go in with the nation
in in in the sauna so we say well
the naked Asian guy had left at least we
thought he did so then we go into the
sauna and who comes [ __ ] walking back
the naked Asian but now he's got a
[ __ ] towel on now he sits down me and
Jay a [ __ ] wearing towels thank God
generally speaking they come from a
polite culture so he leaves his towel on
so I'm thinking all right we're good
here we're [ __ ] good here and I'm
sitting there and the sauna the the the
the sauna isn't hot enough so the door
hasn't clouded up
so we're just sitting there we can see
right out the door and all of a sudden
this other naked guy completely [ __ ]
naked comes walking out of the [ __ ]
the steam thing
just butt ass naked and he's standing
there like [ __ ] Will Ferrell in old
school at the water fountain
bending over getting a goddamn drink and
me and Jay are just laughing our asses
off staring down at the floor going what
the [ __ ] is going on and then the naked
Asian guy crosses his [ __ ] legs and
starts cracking his toes
in the ungodly silence in this [ __ ]
sauna is this [ __ ] Will Ferrell ass
is in front of us
we're just like I can't [ __ ] believe
right so
then we're sitting there and we got this
like I said the window isn't fogged up
then this [ __ ] World War II vet comes
walking by completely [ __ ] naked you
know the greatest Generation they never
put a towel on he comes [ __ ] walking
by old man balls and dick and everything
and we've at this point we're just
[ __ ] what there's nothing to do to
just start laughing
and another guy comes walking and he has
a robe on another type of [ __ ] and he
goes into the sun he goes into the Steam
and finally like look if we just don't
[ __ ] walk in there we're never going
to be able to take a steam and I [ __ ]
hate a son I don't like the dry heat I
like the other thing so we finally come
walking in there
all right and as I walk in I see a place
where I can sit down this is all fogged
up and I see out of the corner of my eye
there's someone else sitting there no
towel on dick and balls hanging out
so I go to shoot the guy a dirty look
and who is it it's the naked Asian
I thought he left he didn't he left got
in the shower and then [ __ ] went back
in there
[ __ ] nightmares and then we're
sitting in there all right
the Will Ferrell naked dude two fat
[ __ ] in the naked Asian and me and Jay
lawhead are sitting in there right
and the football guys now they're
running their yaps
totally killing any sort of relaxing
just sort of chilling out as relaxed as
you can be with [ __ ] you know naked
guys all around you and they're sitting
there they you know former athletes
talking about sports and some sort of
benefit that they would do it oh man
Arizona was unbelievable it's just
hookers everywhere and people drinking
blah blah blah kids guys telling the
story it was some sort of benefit for
kids and in the end he goes you know but
it's all about the kids it's all about
the kids [ __ ] jerk off starts the
story talking about hookers
um
anyways long story short it finally ends
up just being the Two of Us in there and
we're just laughing our covered balls
off
I I've never seen
I've never seen it like that ever
look like if you go to any sort of
[ __ ] gym any sort of locker room
there's gonna be the naked guy the guy
just standing there
right and for you ladies out there you'd
probably think that well it's got to be
the well-endowed guy showing off his
[ __ ] goddamn mule right it it usually
isn't it's usually just [ __ ] some
average guy regular old [ __ ]
user-friendly dick just standing there
you know
like the kind of package that they
always make when they're like sculptors
make
you know they never make like a [ __ ]
huge dick statue
they don't they just draw a regular old
dick that's what it usually is and
there's usually one of them
and you just sit that guy out there's
always one why the [ __ ] does he [ __ ]
not notice he's the only [ __ ] naked
dude in here
for Christ's sake of yourself right but
there's always that one guy unless you
go to the YMCA then there's usually
about three because there's older people
there
I never seen a [ __ ] dick and ball
display like this in my life
I'm [ __ ] believable we would joke and
we were waiting for what's his face
Uncle milty to come walking in
um anyways so that's the dick and ball
story so plowing ahead here oh I
actually said that I was gonna tell you
a [ __ ]
a goddamn creepy story here
um
and I gotta wrap this podcast up because
I got you know well Billy's got a day
job now
tell you what I'll read the rest of the
advertising and then I'll uh
I'll tell you this [ __ ] terrifying
story that I read while on a plane all
right so
the terrifying story that I have been
teasing
teasing you guys about
over the last couple of uh
I don't know minutes here
um
so anyways the shows went great in San
Francisco in San Francisco and
um we're flying back
and uh my wife bought
um Vanity Fair I think
I don't know
um it's the magazine where Robert Downey
Jr is on the cover and he looks like
he's leaning out of the porthole of a
ship
dressed in a tuxedo it makes you think
are they are they remaking the Titanic
it's one of those photos so
she says hey you are you know
she knows I'm a fan obviously guy's
unbelievable [ __ ] actor
and she goes hey this is a great article
you ought to read it so I'm looking in
the table of contents you know it's one
of those magazines you got to go buy 50
pages of advertise advertisements
before
um
you know you get to the actual story and
so I the table of contents so I found
the table of contents
and there was this story about this
flight
um that was flying from Brazil to Paris
France
um and it was talking about technology
and and how this thing just basically
fell out of the [ __ ] sky
because the pilots
was The Perfect Storm of not
communicating getting confused a
malfunction in the
the the system
and um
these guys not being able to recover
it was on you know what the malfunction
was
basically they were flying out
and the uh the captain he'd only got an
hour sleep and he wanted to go take a
nap
they had some thunderstorms or whatever
a line of storm clouds coming up they're
flying at 36 000 feet and this guy
wanted to climb up to 38 which is
basically the ceiling that that plane
could fly at safely because at that
point the air is going to be too thin
and I would assume that the engine has
to work too hard
to suck in the air suck squeeze bang
blow whatever the [ __ ] they say how jet
engine works
um and they said that the guy sounded
nervous it was this weird thing where
the guy had like
the the co-pilot had like over 2500
hours which is a significant amount of
time flying a [ __ ] this type of an
airplane but most of it was just sitting
there while it was on autopilot
and this was kind of the point of of the
um
the article where
uh just through the the whole
timeline of Aviation back in the day you
just had stick and Rudder guys and they
just flew the [ __ ] thing
um
and then gradually they worked in these
automated systems and the pilots were
arguing against them saying there's
nothing better than a thinking
human being and then these automated
systems got so good that the
um
basically accidents and everything went
through the floor
and it became way safer to fly
and the automated systems took over but
now they've gotten to the point where I
don't know if they're saying that they
can actually be dangerous so
basically what happened was the captain
went to go take a nap and then this
other guy goes and he sits down
and there was a miscommunication as to
who the pilot in command was
or who was in command or whatever
and they don't even have sticks anymore
up there they have like a joystick that
you move
and then the system interprets the
movement
like not instantly it has to have that
Split Second where it interprets it and
then it it acts on whatever movement you
did
and
um
the sticks can't the joysticks can't
move at the same time like say if both
people in both
um
both seats up there if one was to move
the joystick to the right and the other
was to move it all the way to the left
what the computer would do would split
the difference on the movement
and
I don't know it just
basically all that happened was they
went into this storm
and the air was cold enough where the
water droplets had formed into ice
crystals and it blocked their pitot tube
the pitot tube is you know is on all
aircraft it's just a tube that points
towards the front of the aircraft and as
you fly
as the air is coming in if that's how
you figure out your air speed so what
happened was they flew through this ice
ice went into the pitot tube it froze it
up so the air couldn't go in anymore
so they no longer
could they lost their uh
their airspeed indicator so they
immediately lost that
all right and they had the lights on in
the cabinet they're out over the ocean
they must have been
then must have not been any Moonlight or
anything so basically they couldn't see
a horizon
all right but all they had to do was
just look
at that little plane thing that just
lets you know if you're level or not
and for some reason when they lost
their airspeed indicator they then lost
all faith in the entire [ __ ] system
and the nervous Nelly guy who wanted to
climb
you know
above the storm he wanted to fly at the
absolute height
his immediate Instinct was he started
pulling the or moving the joystick back
and if you lose all faith in your
instruments and you and you don't have
any Horizon to look at
you don't know where the [ __ ] you're at
and this dude was panicking so he pulled
the stick back too far and it got to the
point where they were gonna stall
and I forget it's such a long [ __ ]
article and it's really involved so he
they start
the other guy starts going no what are
you doing what are you doing do this do
this and he starts moving his thing
and then that the computer is going dual
input meaning that they're both moving
the [ __ ] thing so they start
going up and down and they they
basically the [ __ ] nervous Nelly he
pulls it all the way back
and they start feeling the the airplane
starts rocking and that's that point
where you're gonna stall
because
at that point the airfoil is is so far
back
you're going to lose lift and if the air
is just tumbling over the it's like all
of a sudden now you might as well have a
[ __ ] two pieces of plywood
like flying into the [ __ ] wind so
they start losing altitude
so they see that they're losing altitude
they're basically starting to fall out
of the [ __ ] sky
um and what kills me is in part of this
as they started to drop
they started to basically fall out of
the [ __ ] sky and not recognizing the
sound
of of of
basically is the is the airs rolling
over the [ __ ] wind over the wings
there that they were starting they were
gonna stall
they were so in their head looking at
the [ __ ] screens going what the [ __ ]
this thing's going haywire where are we
they panicked
and this [ __ ] guy kept pulling back
he pulled back the [ __ ] joysticks so
far
they almost got to a 46 degree angle
they said it was so far back that the
computer didn't even recognize that as
an input that would be possible because
no one would do it so it stopped saying
stall that thing that's you know or pull
up pull up it's oh no I wouldn't say
pull up there it stopped warning that
they were going to stall
so then it got quiet and that literally
just falling out of the [ __ ] Sky they
were falling at like
like 10 000 feet per minute at one point
okay so do the [ __ ] math they're like
36 000 feet up they're falling 10 you
got three minutes before you're gonna
hit the deck right so these [ __ ] guys
the one guy goes no level the nose level
in the nose so he goes to level it off
from 46 degrees to start bringing it
back down to something that the computer
could actually understand and as he
brings it down again it starts going
stall stall stall so he pulled back
again so it would stop saying that [ __ ]
and then they're calling the captain and
the captain finally goes up there and
now he's come in in the middle of this
[ __ ] crisis he doesn't know what's
going on he they he at no point was
informed that the pitot tube was frozen
and at this point they had lost so much
altitude that they were down into warmer
air and it unfroze and it was the
airspeed indicator was actually [ __ ]
working but they had no faith in it
and these guys were basically falling
out of the [ __ ] sky and this is the
scariest thing when they get to 12 000
feet
that was the last moment that they had
where they could have just pushed the
joystick forward and started a dive
and that they would at the speed that
they were falling that they would have
had enough time to try to restart those
engines and [ __ ] pull back up again
you know it basically buzzed the surface
of the [ __ ] water
and um
they kept falling they were falling at
one point fifteen thousand feet
per minute
and uh the whole thing they just
basically pancaked into the ocean
in a perfectly good airplane because
their pedo tubes froze
and because they panicked and because I
guess most of their hours is just
sitting there letting something else fly
the [ __ ] plane I never heard of this
story uh I believe it's in Vanity Fair I
can't believe I just said all this [ __ ]
and I can't even tell you and I'm and of
course I'm reading this
on a uh on a flight
and I remember at the end of my flight
this baby-faced looking dude gets out
um Babyface to me I'm 46. he looked like
he wasn't even 30.
and you know he's doing this simple
flight San Francisco to LA nice quick
flight but whatever we're flying
commercial airline we're flying all the
way up there and uh but it was during
the day so that was one thing that was
actually keeping me calm I'm like even
if the pillow tubes were to freeze up
this guy can still see the horizon
um
but anyways man it was absolutely
terrifying and they were writing the
dialogue of the [ __ ] that they were
saying and every input that they would
like describe what the plane was doing
what they should have done and then they
would then they would write out the
dialogue of what they did and what they
said and I'm telling you dude my [ __ ]
heart was in my throat
um so for someone who flies all the
[ __ ] time you know
that wasn't a very fun article to be
reading uh [ __ ] I gotta end this [ __ ]
podcast I didn't even get into any of
the questions for this week uh really
really quickly uh the Patriots came back
against the Bengals and I know a lot of
people are now going to go all the way
to the other side oh they're going to
win the Super Bowl
um I don't think the Patriots were the
team that lost to the uh Chiefs and I
don't think they they were necessarily
that team last night I think that
somewhere in the middle I'm hoping
they're more towards the team that beat
the Bengals but I think we got a couple
more brutal losses in US
um you saw what happened when Revis went
down and I hate to say it but he gets
injured a lot
um the second he got injured they
[ __ ] scored in goddamn two three
plays
but you know what's amazing about
Darrell Rivas even the fact that he's on
our [ __ ] team and that I'm actually
cheering for that guy who I couldn't I
always respected but I hate him because
he was a jet he's only 29 years old
I had no idea he seems like he's been in
the league forever and he also looks
like he's like 37.
um all right let's uh let's plow ahead
in the Jets Jesus Christ j-e-t-s Jess
Jets Jets they're in a [ __ ] bad way
man
they are in a bad goddamn way I didn't
see that one I watched the Cowboys
Texans which was a great game
I I I saw a little bit of the Bills game
big win for them how about the Cleveland
Browns coming back
um and also the Saints a lot of great
games those one o'clock games were
[ __ ] insane this week but uh I got a
plow ahead here let me just read some of
your questions and uh then I'll get out
of here um Aussie with an idea
Bill how about you shooting your next
special in Australia you draw huge
crowds here and when was the last time
someone shot a special down here
um you know what I I did this last one
down south I kind of like taping them a
different place I don't know how to [ __ ]
what kind of cameras do you guys have
over there do you guys make movies over
there do you wait for us to make them
for you that would be my big question do
you have the latest in [ __ ]
the technology
because then maybe you know maybe I
would no I wouldn't hey Bill why don't
you get on a plane and fly 14 hours and
have jet lag and then do your [ __ ]
special I'm not gonna do that I will
definitely be touring your country
though we're looking at January
um all right car dear Billy oil rag I
want to get an old car and learn to fix
it every time I ask someone what make
and model year I should buy they give me
horrible answers can you please narrow
it down to two or three cars from the
late 60s to the early mid 70s that would
be a great car to work on I know there
are a ton of answers just looking for a
place to start I have a little
experience
with parts and repair but not a lot
that's why I want to Dive Right In and
learn thanks uh well look you want to
call you want to you I would ask uh
Christopher Titus
he could give you that answer but I
would tell you what I would do if I was
you
all right what I would do is I would buy
an old [ __ ] engine
all right I would buy that [ __ ] thing
that you that whatever that engine mount
thing is that you can have not engine
mount that thing where you can just have
it on a rotisserie
all right and I would take that entire
[ __ ] thing apart
and rebuild that engine
all right I might even do that a couple
of [ __ ] times
just so I got it down
so that that's how I would learn don't
go out and go buy a whole new a whole
[ __ ] car just go buy a [ __ ] engine
just take the you know
what would you do you'd remove the
carburetor then you got the intake
manifold and you got the valve covers
and you got the valves
take all of that [ __ ] off
then you're down to your [ __ ] your
Pistons right I'm not good with the
electrical or anything like that but
you go all the way you know camshaft all
the way down to the crankshaft and if
you just start over even if you just put
the thing back to [ __ ] gather
with the old [ __ ] although probably
they'll probably have a problem trying
to get some of this [ __ ] off he might
break something but I would just do that
and I would buy if you could buy a four
cylinder I'd look at it the same way I
learned how to tune drums you start with
your smallest drum that had the fewest
amount of lugs so it was easier to tune
because you couldn't make that many
mistakes
so I would actually if you can't buy an
old four-cylinder engine at a junkyard I
would buy an old six cylinder then you
only get six cylinders you got to worry
about or you could just buy the eight
cylinder and then you got to do
everything eight [ __ ] times and
you're gonna be that much better at it
and I think once you [ __ ] tear down
an engine and then just build the thing
back up even if you did a couple two
three times
um I mean I think that that's the way to
go two three times just buy an old
engine buy the whole [ __ ] kit
on how to replace everything
go through the hell of [ __ ] getting
it apart and [ __ ] being stuck and Frozen
and all grouped together get that whole
[ __ ] thing torn apart and then
rebuild the thing make all your [ __ ]
mistakes and then do it again
and then do it again and then do it
again and then do it again and then go
out and buy the [ __ ] car you want to
buy
you know I mean dude you can buy an old
piece of [ __ ] [ __ ] engine for a
couple hundred bucks
and then go buy what I forget how much
the I was gonna do this if I ever had
[ __ ] time in my life I think that
that's the way to go about doing it
rather than buying a whole goddamn car
that's going to have all kinds of other
[ __ ] problems if you just learn how
to do basically the heart of the goddamn
engine I really feel like all of a
sudden
the rest of the car is not going to be
nearly as intimidating maybe the
transmission could get a little uh a
little scary but that's another thing
too go out buy a [ __ ] transmission
take it apart rebuild it put it back
together do it again do it again do it
again
sorry the uh the batteries just
crapped out on me there now I'm [ __ ]
late and I gotta get going here so yeah
that's what I would do if uh if you want
to learn how to you know
how to fix up a car I mean that's that's
that's basically what I would do maybe
if you know people who are in the cars
gear heads out there if you know a
better way to go about it
um which I'm sure you do
but that's basically what I would do and
uh but if you are going to buy a car man
um
I don't know I would maybe uh what are
those cars that always had the Slant six
that everybody says like the greatest
engine and the easiest thing to work on
you know everything's like right in a
row all this spark plugs all of that
stuff is like right there
um
I would work with Dodge Darts I think
usually had those the lower level models
I don't know I'm not I don't know cars
to that level but uh
that is on um
you know I would like to do that at some
point just take apart a whole engine and
then rebuild it and put it back together
even if I didn't put it in something
just sell it or something and give it to
somebody else
um because I think that's cool as hell
to know how to do something like that if
I just had the [ __ ] time in my life
and speaking of time I don't have any
time here so I got to uh I gotta jump
off here uh thanks to everybody
listening to the podcast and uh thanks
everybody in San Francisco those
ridiculous the amount of people that
showed up
um I had a great time and I appreciate
you guys listening to the new material
as I'm working it out as I have a new
special as I mentioned before coming out
on Netflix December 5th called I'm sorry
you feel that way and
um
oh by the way my uh new uh Comedy album
vinyl
um live at Andrew's house is available
for purchase on my website and uh for
those who would like to donate to this
podcast an easy way to do it is if
you're gonna buy something on
um Amazon uh just swing by billboard.com
first click on the podcast page click on
the link I know it's a bit of a pain in
the ass do it if you want to if you
don't I get it and it takes you right to
Amazon and I'll get credit for the for
driving traffic there it won't cost you
any extra money and whatever you buy
they give me like a percentage of uh
whatever that's basically how it works
all right that's it uh that's the
podcast what's up everybody and welcome
back to the anything better podcast
NFL Edition for a bit MGM going into
week number five as you guys can tell I
am sitting here
um alone well not alone we always have
the The Greek Freak is always by your
side you know he's like uh Maverick at
the beginning of Top Gun one where uh
who was it was it Wolfman wait who was
the one that was freaking oh cougar
cougar come on Cougar come on as a kid I
never knew what his problem was he was
just always there shaking like what's
the matter as a little kid you're like
why is he staring at that woman and
child and like yeah you know and now you
realize but uh Andrew stemless says oh
Andrew's like we gotta go Gotta Go get
Paul something's wrong
um we are here
um Bill we have a weird week right now
guys but we're never gonna not do our
picks
um we're never not gonna do our picks
but Bill had to go and take care of a
personal matter I am going to the
airport because I'm going to Europe so
we need to do these picks this way
um but don't you worry because we have
thought out picks and uh we are uh ready
to go but before we get into the picks
we have to of course talk about uh the
BET MGM our amazing sponsor bet MGM as
you guys know we've been working with
bet MGM now for our our second season
we'll be using bet MGM lines to make all
of our picks and we'll have special
offers for our listeners each week if
you haven't signed up for bet MGM yet
use bonus code Burr couldn't be easier
guys
b-u-r-r okay all you got to do is use
that bonus code and you'll get a hundred
percent risk-free up to a thousand on
your first wager here's how it works
you're gonna go to bed MGM uh download
the app you're gonna sign up using bonus
code Burr you're going to deposit uh at
least ten dollars and place your first
wager on the game you'll receive up to a
thousand in free bets which is
incredible if you lose uh even if it
loses uh just make sure you use bonus
code Burr when you sign up and these are
the best lines out there guys that's why
we use them now
going so what's going to happen with
this episode is you're going to hear my
picks and then Andrew will cut and you
will hear Bill's picks okay uh we have
the lines even though we're in different
locations not doing the show together we
know exactly what's going on in the NFL
so last week I believe I I will I know I
went two and two because uh the Detroit
Lions and the Bucks screwed me over but
I did get
um I did get uh the who won for me the
uh the the who did I pick I picked the
Chargers definitely one for me and the
Cowboys that's right so I had the
Chargers and Cowboys thought the lions
were gonna come back and I was gonna
start 3-0 going into that Buccaneers
game but uh what could I say man maybe
the Chiefs are gonna make me eat my
words they went into Tampa beat Brady
after a loss bucks got back to back
losses so I go two and two and uh Andrew
did Bill go one and three
I think Bill might have went one and
three
um
but we will have all of that yeah we'll
have all that information so there you
go bill goes one and three I go two and
two and uh we looked at the we looked at
the um lines so we will do our picks uh
we'll do our picks now
all right so this is this is a div last
week the lines were kind of
close and similar now you got eight and
a half Point lines 14 point lines three
point lines seven five and a half it's a
weird week Andrew it's all over the
place this week but
um all right so one of my picks here out
of my four I'm not gonna say my first
because Bill is gonna do his but um my
I'm gonna go with my first pick of this
episode will be I have to do it I'm
gonna be there it's the New York
football Giants I'm on the field guys I
mean I'm on the field with my family in
London to see my New York football
Giants play the Packers by the way the
Giants are three in one they're going
against the Juggernaut
um Aaron Rodgers but here's why I like
the pick I like the pick because we are
getting eight and a half points and
we're in London we're gonna be fired up
you control the clock with saquon
Barkley you let saquon Barkley run I'm
not saying we win the game I think
there's a chance but uh so you're saying
there's a chance
um but I think the way we can control
the clock with the running game if we
could give him some protection there
um I like the eight and a half points so
I'm going to take the New York football
Giants plus eight and a half with me and
my family there in London for no other
reason one of the Giants needs to listen
to our podcast and say hey let's do this
for old Paulie
come on man he's getting his wife and
kids are there my daughter and son are
going to be in jerseys what are you
gonna do lose by nine
all right
this is where it gets tricky guys okay
this is where it gets tricky because
like these these games I said there's a
lot of
there's a lot of weird ones like the
Rams need a win because the Rams are in
you know two and two but the Cowboys are
clicking do I touch that I don't know
does Bill touch that I don't know the
Raiders won so did the Chiefs do I touch
that I don't know I'm gonna tell you
what I'm gonna do with my second pick
though when I'm gonna do it my second
pick is
the Jacksonville I don't know why I'm
doing this
okay it's hard to say the Jacksonville
Jaguars with seriousness but
they were in that game against the
Eagles dude in Philly they were in that
game as a matter of fact they were
winning that game 14 to nothing
then the Eagles come back I'm gonna take
the Jaguars minus seven at home after a
loss you know my theory
a good to decent team after a loss
coming home they're playing the hapless
Houston Texans I like the Jacksonville
Jaguars to bounce back Trevor Lawrence
to have a big game I like the Jaguars to
win that game by a touchdown so I'm
going to take minus seven for the jacks
all right
um not touching that one
I know Bill's going to touch that game
and I'm just going to be a gentleman and
let him take it I think
um
I'm gonna take the Los Angeles Chargers
again
on the road minus three Herbert is fully
healed
I'm gonna take the Chargers going into
Cleveland winning that game by a field
goal I love it that it's only three
points minus three my third pick will be
the Los Angeles Chargers uh a healed
ribbed a healed ribs uh Justin Herbert
wins that game so I'm gonna take that
one
and
for my
final pick I will take
oof oh my God I almost just did
something Andrew and I it was like when
you're about to hit the golf ball and
then you step back you know like you
line up and you think it's right and
then I just was like I need to take a
step back but
I'll take the Thursday night game I'm
gonna take the Broncos at home after a
loss there's the theory there's my
theory that's actually the perfect
example of my theory for you people that
don't know I have a homecoming Theory
and my homecoming theory is exactly that
a good to decent team
okay they lost a tough one to the
Raiders the Raiders needed a win they
got it now Russell Wilson goes home
against the Indianapolis Colts again
it's a low line three should the Broncos
beat the Colts by three in Denver yes
they should those are my picks
um and right now it is time for the what
for the Monday night special it's time
for the Monday night special everybody
and this Monday night I'm not gonna lie
it's a doozy it is a division rival it
is the Las Vegas Raiders
coming off their first win
going into the Kansas City Chiefs who
keep winning
and it is a seven point spread the under
over is 51.
okay
um
right off the bat I like the under right
off the bat I like under 51. okay that's
a lot of that's a lot of touchdowns you
know that's what's 48 points is how many
touchdowns is 49 uh four right four
touchdowns is 49.
no so seven touchdowns is 49 seven times
seven is 49.
Jesus Scott how bad is my math five is
five times that is 35. so wow so that's
a lot of touch that's seven total
touchdowns I don't know why I was
thinking I don't know why I yeah that
would be actually the way my math was
I'm like oh 28 is four I don't know how
I got that there's some two-point
conversions in your head well I was yeah
I don't know what I was thinking dude
that's thank God that that's why I don't
help my son with his algebra
um
okay
so I like the under
and and Bill and I are in agreement that
I'll just read these days off for the
Monday night special I like under 51.
um that's a lot of touchdowns even if
they that's seven I like that so uh as a
matter of fact seven touchdowns can
happen and we still win the bet so I'm
gonna take we're gonna go under 51 to
start now here's where it gets tricky
do the Raiders go in there
and lose a close game which I think can
happen
you think what do you think Andrew you
think the Raiders are gonna win no I
actually think the Chiefs are going to
win and I think they're going to blow
them out I think the Raiders look good
overall like I mean I'm they're coming
into certain weeks where I'm like yeah
the Raiders can win this game I I don't
I don't I don't I I right now
I mean the Chiefs win this game by more
than seven is that what you're thinking
no I think they worked out most of their
problems for now maybe not playoffs but
for now you're talking about the Chiefs
yeah I'm saying the Chiefs are worked
have worked out most of their problems
and and and they're they're still
they're still
well who's gonna make it happen over car
in the fourth quarter my home's gonna
make it happen over car in the fourth
quarter is definitely something that I
think most people agree with but here's
the thing
the Raiders cannot this is borderline I
mean I don't want to go as far as saying
playoff implications but here's a deal
the Raiders are the Raiders are one and
three dude if the Raider the Raiders are
one and three dude with Devonte Adams
this is a division rival Bill always
talks about those now you know when I
see those division rivalry games even
when both teams are bad like the Falcons
saying stuff like that it's always close
if the Raiders go one in four their
chances of doing anything this year are
finished so I think that they go into
the game and we get better odds for our
fans I like the seven points I like the
seven points I like the Raiders I'm not
saying the Raiders gonna win the game by
any stretch
but I could see the Chiefs beating them
by a field goal
and the Raiders hanging in there also
the Raiders are kind of flying high with
their first win maybe they think they
might have figured something out they
were playing a decent team in the
Broncos and it'll be better odds for the
people I don't know I think Carr and
Devonte Adams start something this week
you know I think everybody's taken the
Chiefs which makes me not like it
um so we're gonna go we're gonna take
the points Andrew we're gonna take the
plus seven points we're gonna take under
51
and we will take
um
I mean my home's to throw one is not
going to be great odds right should we
do Derek Carr to throw one
if you think that they're gonna they're
gonna cover then he's gonna have to
throw them
Derek Carr I mean if the if the under
over is 51 and I mean Derek whoever he's
gonna have to throw three so if you
believe it yeah and he's got Devonte
Adams I like that I think Derek Carr to
throw one will take the Raiders getting
seven and we'll take under 51 for the
Monday night special guys I'll be honest
I really like that I really like that
the only thing that would suck is if it
starts out 21 nothing but I like car to
throw one like you said he almost has to
which is a really good if you like his
covers you can't put money on them
covering and not put money on car
throwing one well that's that's exactly
right and and maybe the defenses hold a
little till 51 that means Vegas thinks
this is going to be a big time shootout
which is another reason why car is going
to throw on but we're gonna do that so
there you go everybody that's the Monday
night special Derek Carr to throw a
touchdown the Raiders getting seven and
under uh 51 overall points will be your
Monday night special for the anything
better
um bed MGM NFL preview for week number
five enjoy Bill's picks all right with
my first pick
Oh Billy winless the one win Wonder one
and three every [ __ ] week I like the
Tennessee Titans minus two against the
Washington commanders I don't know why
this only
it's only two points I have no idea I
don't know if there's somebody hurt on
Tennessee Commander's got their ass
kicked against the Eagles and then they
[ __ ] the bet against the Cowboys and I
bet them last week and they [ __ ] me so
uh so [ __ ] them
because I'm Petty this is a petty bet
telling you right now minus two I'm also
I'm taking I'm taking the Colts
Colts I think are are they're like this
they're like this they're like this
they're like they're they're [ __ ]
doing everybody thinks oh you know uh
Reggie Theus being the quarterback now
of uh Reggie Lewis
why can't I ever remember his [ __ ]
name the guy from Seattle is the
quarterback of the Broncos they think
he's going to come in what's his name
what's his name Russell Wilson thank you
Mike bertolina it all thinks comedy I'm
gonna take the Colts plus three
I mean I mean like the game hasn't even
started I already have three points why
wouldn't I do that
first drive easy seven what the [ __ ] did
I all right I'm also gonna throw I'm
gonna take my New England Patriots minus
three against the hapless Detroit Lions
Detroit Lions you know what the problem
is over there Andrew
the first guy who bought the team was a
football guy and he knew football and
they won three [ __ ] titles yes they
did all right with that that Bobby Lane
guy going out [ __ ] hitting the
Hooters the first Hooters the original
one in 1953 right and then ever since
then they keep passing it down to the
family and evidently nobody taught those
kids how to throw because they can't
[ __ ] run a team to save their life
they set some point they need to step
out it's like a whole family of Jerry
Jones's you know it's just like just
shut up and let the football people do
you know go get a facelift get out of
here all right so I got Tennessee minus
two I got the Colts plus three I got the
Patriots minus three and you know what
what's going on with those Dolphins is
he coming back
he's coming back
yes no he's supposed to play but there
was a concussion protocol last week that
people or they she should have had
gone into this there's an Italian in the
corner saying I doubt it and I'm talking
gambling here so I'm gonna you know
you dance with who brung you uh
am I gonna oh Los Angeles charges first
he took that you [ __ ] goddamn son of
a [ __ ]
all 580 took it didn't you
um
I don't know where to go from here
San Francisco
uh what do you think Mike they're gonna
go in there Mike bartolin everybody
they're minus five and a half going into
Carolina where they got Baker Mayfield
with something to prove
Dodge
what do you mean he's dog [ __ ] the guy
the guy won a playoff game for the
[ __ ] Browns oh look at this we are
the the league right now that's probably
okay he's playing for the Panthers you
know what I mean
all right [ __ ] it I'm taking the 49ers
because a guy from San Francisco just
told me so
I love Italians I can't lay off you know
what I mean I just feel like there's
going to be wine and some [ __ ] food
or some [ __ ] all right those are my
picks and what do we do for the Monday
night special
uh Paul wanted under 51 uh the Raiders
plus seven and car to throw one
I like that the radius the Raiders are
dupe
this is make or break for the Raiders
right now so that's why he made a case
for that uh you know you know what I
think they come out and they wear those
white jerseys with the silver numbers
everybody gets a little more amped up
and I think they come up and I think
they cover they bust some people in from
Oakland it's going to happen this week
yeah real Old School Oakland people yeah
okay not not not the [ __ ] uh Rocky
Horror Picture Show rate of fans I mean
yeah yeah those [ __ ]
the guys who stabbed those people at the
[ __ ] Stones concert right they bring
those guys in at 80. all right that's it
those are my picks uh Gamble responsibly
and and there we go man that's uh that's
pretty much what we got
um when I come back from the trip and
Bill's back and everything is better we
will do be doing another anything better
so for all the fans asking what's going
on it's just been with Bill uh doing
stuff with a project with uh my
traveling now coming back in the middle
of the month that's what's going on but
the Greek Freak is on it so all you guys
reaching out going oh you guys still
doing yes we're still doing it we're
just gonna finish out uh what we're
doing and don't forget don't don't
forget to tell the listeners that they
can watch you on the NFL Network in
London that's true that's true for all
the [ __ ] that you hear me talk on this
um you know your boy's not just your
boys the NFL knows about your boy make
no mistake about that so I will be on uh
NFL Networks uh and NFL Total Access on
um so I'm I'm filming it Wednesday night
so we're it's what it's it's six hours
ahead and I'm gonna be on in the eight
o'clock hours so let's do the math on
that yeah uh I don't know it's five
hours difference or six five it's five
yeah okay so it'll be around I guess two
o'clock it'll be around two o'clock in
the afternoon on Wednesday
um and it'll be Wednesday night where I
am but I will be live on there with uh
host Derek Carr I'm gonna be oh no not
Derek Carr that's uh his brother David
Carr is one of the hosts so we'll be
talking about that hey I'll even tell
him I took his brother how about that
um and uh you guys could check that out
as well also don't forget if you go to
Paul verzy's uh the Pulver is a YouTube
channel
um you can check out my last appearance
on good morning football or at least a
segment on it with the Tom Brady stuff
check out the Versi effect check out
Bill's Monday Morning podcast all the
stuff that we have guys if you're
listening to this right now and you're
going to be in DC October 19th I will be
doing one night at the DC Improv and
then the next night on the 20th I'll be
at the Philadelphia punch line all right
and if you are listening to this and
you're in the UK we added a show
um so this is a Saturday night at 10 p.m
in London I will be at 21 Soho
performing there there you have it those
are our picks do not forget to download
okay the BET MGM app use
bonus code b u r r couldn't be more
simple all right and all you got to do
is put a minimum of ten dollars you're
gonna get up to a thousand dollars in
free bets and even if it loses just make
sure you put in the bonus code uh Burr
and you will be able to bet with that
and get up to a thousand dollars which
is phenomenal they have the best lines
and I gotta tell you working with them
these first two seasons has been an
absolute pleasure so
um check out those lines enjoy your NFL
uh football Sunday and Monday and
Thursday for week number five and let's
uh let's see uh if we can um get some
wins here and make you guys some money
with the Monday night special as well
that is it for uh for us and remember
guys to bet you got to be 21 years of
age or older to wager in Arizona
Colorado DC Iowa Indiana Kansas Michigan
Mississippi New Jersey New York Nevada
Pennsylvania Sylvania Tennessee
Virginia West Virginia or Wyoming only
new customer offer paid in free bets
visit betmgm.com for terms and
conditions uh excludes Michigan
disassociated persons uh please gamble
responsibly gambling problem call 1-800
next step for Arizona call
1-800-522-4700 for Colorado DC Nevada
Wyoming West Virginia
1-800-270-7117 for confidential help
Michigan
1 800 Gambler in Indiana New Jersey
Pennsylvania and West Virginia
1-800 bets off in Iowa call or text the
Tennessee Red Line
800-889-9789 in Tennessee or call
1-88-77-9696 for Mississippi sports
betting is void in Georgia Hawaii Ohio
and Utah and other states were
prohibited promotional offers not
available in Nevada
[Applause]
[Music]